part of the house Ways and Means
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of covid-19
pandemic and in accordance with the
house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing of bills
referred to the Ways and Means Committee
executive sessions on pending
legislations may be held
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporarily to
this meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporary contemporarily during this
meeting through the Zone electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to the Contemporary Society
listen and if necessary to participate
in this meeting by the zoom platform or
by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting applies with
house rules RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271-3600
[Music]
or email HCS leg.state.nh.us
um
[Music]
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meetings or call
271-3600 or email HCS life.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
I want to introduce the staff that are
on the meeting assisting us which
consists of Jennifer floor the committee
researcher
yeah
please note that all votes that have
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll calls vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member states
their presence please also State whether
there is anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know why
Russian Colorado thank you Mr chairman
uh let's begin the roll call with
Representative Patrick o'bromi president
here State House
representative Mary Griffin at present I
met my home alone in Windham
representative ulery
this present at home alone
present at home with six cats my wife
will be returning soon
very good representative Fred Doucette
president
representative berstein is your stroke
today and I'm here in concert
representative Robert Elliott
representative Elliott
you tell him earlier right
president and my wife's in the bedroom
do you hear me yes thank you
representative
present at home Salem New Hampshire with
my wife and daughter somewhere in the
house representative hurricane
representative Tim Baxter
Tim H said he'll be late we'll get back
to him representative Walter spilsbury
representative spilsbury
representative Paul Tudor here in
Northwood in a cell or alone wife and
grandkids upstairs thank you
representative Susan almi
representative Albi
representative Richard Ames
I'm here in Jeffrey alone in my home
office and susanami representative Omni
will be late thank you representative
Thomas Southworth
representative Southworth I'm here alone
in Dover representative Dennis Malloy
this is uh Dennis Malloy in Greenland
New Hampshire and my spouse is in the
house
the president representative Thomas
schanberg
representative Schamberg here at the LLB
committee room representative Edith
Tucker
representative Tucker
representative go Marlow
I'm here in Swansea alone
representative Thomas Goffman
representative lockman
representative Amanda Gordon here in my
home office in Lee by myself
representative Mary hacken Phillips
present this morning for my office in
Concord alone
representative James Murphy Jim Murphy
here in Hanover with my wife and
daughter elsewhere in the home
representative Norm major
present near the LLB
go back uh representative Tim Baxter
representative Walter spilsbury yeah
excellent so uh
let's see 20 of it says here three of us
aren't
thank you
we have a busy schedule today and we'll
start off with house like public hearing
on House Bill 533
which is an act establishing a division
of investigation and compliance in the
Lottery Commission
the prime sponsor is representative
Romney representative Romney referring
to introduce to the bill
thank you Mr chair can we just do a
sound check can everybody hear me
yes okay thank you I'm kind of an
awkward here I'm halfway between where
everybody's sitting in the camera you'll
see my profile
uh my words are more important than the
profile that's for sure
I'm here to introduce oh first off State
red Pat of Romney for the record uh
Rockingham 19 Stratham New Hampshire
I'm here to introduce House Bill 533
establishing a division of investigation
and compliance in the Lottery Commission
I filed this bill at the request of
Charlie McIntyre the executive director
of the lottery
The Spill uh does four things
first it formally creates a division of
investigation and compliance within the
Lottery Commission
the bill creates a structure really a
structure only
to be staffed by existing
employees this bill does not ask for
additional staff it's very important to
understand that
in doing so it clearly outlines the
duties of investigation and compliance
again most of these Duties are being
done today but he wants this caught a
codified in law as to what the duty of
this division would be
the second thing it does it changes the
way in which the lottery interacts with
the AG's office when it comes to
background checks required for licenses
in short a lot of the lottery will do a
lot of the data Gathering
uh more closely with the AG's office but
the AG's office will still have the
final stay as to the fitness of an
applicant that receives a license
the thought behind this is that it will
speed up the process if these people do
this data Gathering
uh and this is not taking any final
Authority away from the AG's office in
this this regard
and the fourth thing is it uh it does
give the investiga this division this
new division of Investigation
enforcement of the rule-making authority
and the last thing and for new members
uh I just want to spend a second uh
using this bill to hopefully have the
bill in front of you
uh the first thing the creation of
division is on page one of the Bell
lines 1 to 22. what it does is it says
amend
by adding a new section so this is a
whole new section of law
the second the second portion is on page
123p line 23 to 31 and page two line one
to line 18.
and it says it starts with amend section
of statue this amends a section of
statute
and you will see bold italic that's the
new words for this section and you'll
see crossed out uh words and that is
eliminating current words from statute
and then if you go to uh line 19 to 23
on on page two that is the proportion
that adds new language new section to
the current statute uh that gives them
uh rule making Authority
so it's important for new members to
understand and again this is nothing new
with the bill it's just me just pointing
it out since I was the first stop on
this
so uh the again and the final thing was
the effective date which was January 1
of 2022.
you're going to come to find ways to
meet members that there's a difference
between applicability date and effective
date so the law will be signed into law
by let's say if we pass this probably in
June or July about the signature of the
governor for passes through the house
and the Senate
but the law is not effective
until January 1st of 2022. that's what
that means
so with that uh I know uh
executive director Charlie McIntyre is
hopefully Mr chair we can hear from him
next to explain a little further and uh
I'll take questions but I think uh okay
Tom oh
so you'll take questions now yeah
although uh yeah I'll take a few I think
Charlie will do a better job explaining
are there any questions
uh representative
thank you Mr chairman uh I think it's a
very important
approach you're taking on this because
of dealing with money uh we need
enforcement to make sure people are
following rules only question I have do
you have a uh Financial note to go with
this yet representative abrami again
there's no because
he's not asking for new positions here
he's asking for this division to be
codified in law this and he wants to
create a formally created division now
you can ask Charlie I mean executive
director McIntyre uh that question as
well but thank you my understanding is
that it's just creating the structure
is going to fill up with existing people
now down the road he may ask for people
but through the normal budget process
through his budget request that would go
to finance that's my understanding of
the situation thank you any further
questions
I don't see any hands waves
so
thank you the list that have signed up
is uh next would be Charlie McIntyre
who's the director
Charlie McIntyre
you gotta you gotta we gotta let him in
I I just did it might take a second
good morning I'm I'm actually in it took
it takes about three seconds
to log me in
can you folks hear me
okay perfect
so uh good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee this is Charlie
McIntyre New Hampshire lottery director
and with me in my office is our chief
compliance officer uh John Conforti to
answer any questions you might have
um fundamentally this is
enhancing and codifying the area
regarding an investigation and
compliance and gambling in the state and
doing a couple things as representative
abrami correctly points out one is
allowing us to do the investigation and
background work for the AG's office so
that we can do it and present it to them
they still have the authority to say yes
or no but certainly it would be a
priority for us also we are steeped in
gambling so we tend to know areas a
little bit better
um than they would it's so that it would
be a faster turnaround for us and we
take a burden off of them uh there's no
additional requests for Staffing
um based on the merger with charitable
gambling and racing from four years ago
we have increased the amount of staff to
do this function so now there's about 12
to do it regularly versus when I took it
I think there were three
so we're far more
staffed up in investigation function
um it also enhances penalties for
illegal gambling under current law we
have the authority to investigate
illegal gambling and then do nothing
with it which doesn't seem to make a
whole lot of sense
um and so there's that function as well
and then there's an enhanced
authorization to
um
connect with other law enforcement
receive information from them
um is part of the bill so that's our
request uh like I said happy to answer
any questions from the committee
representative schanberg thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony Mr
McIntyre
um
if the day comes
when you need an increase in this
division of investigators
will that be automatically done within
your office or will you return to one of
the Committees
um actually that's a good question
representative so um we have a number of
open positions that are funded that we
haven't filled yet because we didn't see
a need
um we're not you know fans of just staff
and folks because we have to open
positions we use them judiciously as you
can imagine so absent an expansion of
gambling we wouldn't need to come back
to the legislature for additional
positions
thank you thank you Mr chairman
further questions
yeah I have a question
all right
um
representative Amanda
thank you
thank you um director this is
representative Amanda gorg and I have
just a quick question for you
um what can you share the conversations
that you've had with the attorney
generals uh and let us know what their
thoughts are on this change
so certainly um so our chief compliance
officer John good 40 was formerly the
AG's office and he had the conversation
so he'll answer for us sure so we we did
have a conversation with the
investigators who have been assisting us
um and I think they're aware that this
change is happening and from my
understanding there isn't any objection
from um from the Department of Justice
at this point in time I know that at
presently the investigations that we
send over are
um our lower priority for them obviously
uh given the other uh very important
work that they do
um and so again as uh director McIntyre
said this isn't taking them out of the
equation for the decision making it's
just taking some of the legwork off of
their plate
right and there's been nobody from the
ages officer just signed up on this bill
uh representative Ames
thank you thank you this is for director
McIntyre and my question relates to the
subparagraph
for of node 284 3A that uh sets up a
system for
uh petitioning for Equity relief with
the superior court for uh pen enhanced
penalty uh not to see a fifty thousand
dollars per violation and uh could you
uh sort of fully explain that you you
referred to this new Authority but I'd
like to know the uh the reasoning and
what's new about it as compared with
where you are now great we're glad John
sure uh representative this is Jonathan
for you again I'm going to jump in and
answer that question so the thought
process behind this is uh presently
there is some finding Authority uh with
respect to certain violations but they
are
um very
um the the dollar amounts are very small
um and so there it was a concern that
um as charitable gaming May uh get uh
larger
um that some of the fines would be
effective uh would be ineffective uh as
a turn so this section
basically permits us to go over the
existing fine structure by going to
court that will be fleshed out
completely within rulemaking in terms of
uh what what would uh what would
constitute an enhanced uh penalty under
the statute
um what we are what we anticipate would
be things like repeated violations uh or
or things that strike at the very heart
of the Integrity of the charitable
gaming or the charitable gaming system
and that would permit us uh of course
with the assistance of the Attorney
General's office to go to court and get
a very particular relief that isn't
available to us within the current
statutory framework
Charlie you might have done this but
could you re-identify the person that
just spoke oh certainly sorry it's uh
John 40 our chief Appliance officer
thank you
next questions from representative John
Janine
hi James thank you Mr chairman
um my my question is uh more of a
general nature is there was there any
one event that that triggered the need
for this bill or is it kind of a sense
that gambling operations are growing and
there needs to be more oversight or
something else yeah representative thank
you
for the more of the latter
um certainly I I took over this agency
10 years ago and we were doing 200
million dollars a year in revenue and
this year we'll perhaps in terms of
overall betting it'll across a billion
dollars all all in sports betting
charitable gambling
Kino internet traditional lottery so
it's
it's hard to scale the business and this
is part of that scaling up is really
enhancing our compliance and
investigation function which in any
gambling operation is a critical
function it's one of the three major
functions you would have so it's more to
their latter Point representative
right okay thank you
you have a follow-up representative
no no follow-up I don't see any more
hands raised
okay
you represented Spielberg thank you Mr
chairman
uh
so it's my understanding that this
doesn't really change the nature of
enforcement it just shifts the
responsibility from the Attorney
General's office into your office where
it's going to get more urgency and more
Focus
and that seems fine to me my question is
what is the special fund
established in RSA 284
21-j into which fines are deposited
that's our that's our normal that's
education fund so that's the fund all of
our revenues are deposited into from
which our expenses are
paid and then the residual is left over
for the education trust fund transfer
which is monthly around 10 million
thank you
any further questions
I don't see
all right let's just check the list here
next would be Rick Norman signed up to
testify and support
Rick Nolan
thank you Mr chairman can you hear me
okay
yes
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Rick Newman I
represent the New Hampshire charitable
gaming operators Association
the charitable gaming operators
Association are the uh facilities are
made up of the facilities that do
charity gaming under two RSA
287d commonly known as poker rooms so
just to distinguish from uh bingo halls
or whatnot so those are that's the
association I represent
um
there are about 750 licensees
working in that industry we support over
500 Charities annually
with contributions in the range of
around 12 million dollars a year
annually going to Charities from these
rooms and we are here uh to briefly uh
support this legislation the the number
one
um item of importance in any gambling is
integrity and that it's imperative that
the public and Regulators legislators
are confident that any gambling whether
it be
in Las Vegas Atlantic City or Manchester
New Hampshire that there is integrity in
the game and we are committed
uh to seeing that that happens I think
just to give you one example of a change
that is of substance in this bill the
current law direct mentioned it I just
want to re re-emphasize it is that
currently
while there are certainly illegal
gambling is illegal there have been
times when there's been
suspected illegal gambling and it really
while you can point it out there's
nothing anyone can do about it this bill
gives some specific authority to the
Lottery Commission
to be able to enforce and penalize those
who might engage in illegal gambling
um so I I believe that this is a very
good change uh it will make enforcement
efficient and our members support it
wholeheartedly
thank you Mr chairman
thank you any questions
[Music]
I have the Blue Shield
shows that
Eric Laughlin
representing himself
it was not in support of the bill
and then Thomas
[Music]
member from the public
representing himself neutral on the bill
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm supporting
Thomas designs it was neutralize
[Music]
no other question
from the participants and on those
attending virtually and opposing the
public hearing on House Bill 533.
stuff
thank you
[Music]
okay
I'm going to open the public hearing on
House Bill
568-1 FM a
an act increasing exemptions to the
interest in dividend tax
and we're failing the tax in 2025.
the crime sponsored we representative
cyber sober
and
is representative sober
who am I letting in
yes Norm
okay
find him
oh someone already did okay
you should be good to go
I don't know if you can hear me or see
me
we can hear you more important to hear
me than to see me
uh I'm Norm Silber of state
representative from Belknap County
District 2 which is the towns of
Guilford and Meredith
I'm the prime sponsor of the bill and
there are numerous co-sponsors in the
house and a couple from the Senate
what the bill seeks to do is to
currently the interest in dividends tax
which we've had for a long time in New
Hampshire is a flat five percent above a
threshold
the threshold has varied right now the
threshold is uh twenty four hundred
dollars for an individual and double
that for a married couple
the bill would increase the throughout
the filing threshold it would double it
next year triple it in 2023 quadruple it
in 2024 and in 2025 the tax would
disappear entirely
the um right now there are six states in
the country that have no personal income
tax and 11 that have a personal income
tax with a rate lower than our five
percent rate
the revenues from the IND tax to the
state based on the latest information
from the dra from their website is that
the only element of revenues that is
smaller than the IND tax there's two the
communications tax and the tobacco
settlement right now uh total uh
revenues from the IND tax are less than
two percent of the total revenues
so
what the problem is here is that this
there's two problems one is
on whom does the tax fall and the second
is uh basically a truth in taxation type
of argument
we have been holding ourselves out in
New Hampshire for a very long time as
having no personal income tax but the
reality is is that we do have a personal
income tax and it's the IND tax
um in fact chapter 77 of the RSA is
entitled taxation of incomes so we're
really misleading people who might
consider moving to New Hampshire that we
don't have a personal income tax when in
fact we do
um there's not a lot of there is a lot
of anecdotal evidence that people might
be deterred from moving to New Hampshire
because of the IND tax particularly
retirees who have substantial savings
and Investments and I have personally
been contacted by some people from out
of state asking about the IND tax and
whether it was ever going to be
eliminated or you know repealed or
reduced because they were thinking about
New Hampshire versus Florida aside from
weather considerations
so basically uh what who gets who gets
hit with the tax Savers investors
seniors and retirees who have
accumulated Investments on which they
rely to live so the people who can
probably least afford to pay the tax or
who am I just up and move to another
state without such an onerous tax get
hit with a tax it's a very small portion
of our state's Revenue uh it contributes
to misleading the public I see ads
sometimes On The Wall Street Journal for
from real estate brokers advertising
properties in New Hampshire and one of
the reasons I say why to move to New
Hampshire is we have no personal income
tax well we know that's that's just not
true so what we're trying to do is
basically conform our tax policy to what
we've been saying it is which is that we
have no personal income tax
um do we continue to misrepresent to the
rest of the world that we have no
personal income tax and my view is that
we should not uh it is a very small
portion of our revenues and we should uh
engender trust in our citizens by
saying the truth and doing the tax the
tax policy should be truthful I'm sure
there are other arguments that can be
made on both sides of this but there is
a lot of support for phasing us out we
can wean ourselves off this text over a
period of four years uh I would in 2017
I introduced a bill that would have
basically wiped out the tax in one swoop
and that did not appeal to anyone so
this way the way it's designed by
increasing the filing threshold
gradually over three years in the fourth
year of repeal we can wean ourselves off
because we can see how what the revenue
decline is and adjust the budget
accordingly so that's the reason for
this I would like to see uh an ODP from
the committee on this and I'm available
to answer any questions
okay any questions for the represent
inside
the next we will go to Greg Moore right
as a lobbyist in American for prosperity
of New Hampshire and supported the bill
and wants to testify
Greg Moore
I don't see him on the attendees list is
it Aiden by chance
are you Greg Moore
Aiden Moore
I don't know
okay
and we will go to
um
let me try one more time
is
is this Greg Moore
it's like we've muted Maurice from The
Liquor Commission
Aiden Moore is from The Liquor
Commission
so we'll go to Devin American girl right
would you like me to move on to Devin
Broderick
that was from the dra
um
thank you chairman members of the
committee my name is Devin Roderick I'm
a financial analyst with the New
Hampshire Department of Revenue tax
policy legislative analysis group I'm
also joined by Melissa Rollins I was
hoping you could also promote her in
case she needs answer any questions as
well can you hear me okay yes
as uh representative silver had
explained the proposed Bill increases
both the filing threshold for the IND
tax
in basically three increments as well as
increasing the exemptions that are
provided for the IND tax those include
the
exemption Force being 65 years of age or
older is also a blind exemption in a
disabled exemption and those apply to
both the principal Filer and the spouse
for those who file joint returns
it increases those exemptions like I
said over three three taxable years
and then eventually repeals the IND tax
applicable to taxable periods beginning
after December 31st 2024.
there is no way for the Department of
Revenue to determine the exact fiscal
impact of increasing exemptions under
the IND tax and repealing it all
together
hence in our fiscal note it was an
indeterminable decrease in general fund
Revenue such as where the IND tax is
deposited
the department has no definitive method
also to determine any future IND tax
liability or credit carry forward
amounts
however using available data from tax
year 2019 we are able to estimate the
fiscal impact from the proposed bill
as follows we looked at
um tax year 2019 liabilities being
reported by taxpayers as being
113.8 million
exemptions actually claimed in 2019 were
used to estimate the proposed increases
per year
we also did an analysis based on prior
years breakout to apply that tax year
Revenue to a fiscal year basis
um in the fiscal known and also in the
um
fiscal quick guide we attached a chart
which shows the estimated revenue on a
year-over-year basis as well as well as
the cumulative fiscal impact eventually
reaching the 113.8 million as mentioned
a minute ago as being the tax year 19
total liability
just please note that our fiscal
estimated fiscal impact does not take
into account any overpayments or credit
carry forwards on file the use of these
overpayments could further increase the
loss in Revenue as taxpayers stop making
payments and supplement the payments
with overpayments they haven't file
before the taxes repealed
we also have no way of determining how
the taxpayer would utilize the
overpayment whether they would use it or
multiple years or they would claim it as
a refund once the tax is repealed
similarly similarly there could be
trailing amounts of IND tax collected
even once the uh the tax is fully
repealed from audit and collection
activity
please note that there were a couple
there are a couple outstanding items
that we identified as technical defects
with the bill
um section 13 of the proposed bill would
interfere with dra collection and audit
activity which may occur after the
proposed repeal based on the way it's
written
it interferes with the statute
limitations as outlined in RSA 21j29
we would recommend a repeal that
accommodates the collection audit
activity within the statute of
limitations
and lastly section two of the proposed
bill which addresses the increases in
exemptions
uses the terminology tax year
ending December 31st of each change the
department would recommend stating
taxable periods ending on or after
December 31st instead of the word tax
year for purposes of Fairly
administering the tax
I am available for any questions if you
have any
questions
thank you Mr chair thank you Devin yes
representative schanberg here
what questions if I may Mr chair
do you have the total number
of taxpayers in this
IND and secondly
is there a statistical breakdown of
individuals versus
Partnerships limited reliability
companies and associations that pay into
the IND
just numbers
uh so I can answer the first part now
um for for tax year 2019 data there were
a total of 70 437 IMD returns filed for
2019.
um 37 340 of those returns claimed
exemptions
as far as the breakdown by entity if you
hold on one moment please
so in our I would like to point out one
resource or the dra annual report
available on our websites
um under tax year
individual and Joint filers represented
97.3 percent
of the overall population
and represented conversely about 98.4
percent of the liability
Estates and Partnerships
represented about
um
about two and a half percent of the
population
in about two percent of the liability
thank you
welcome
further questions
we're going to go back and see if Greg
Moore is here he is here now attendance
is great
representative representative Malloy had
his hand up sorry to interrupt oh I'm
sorry representative Roy another
question
yes sir thank you for uh taking uh thank
you Mr chairman for
um
recognize me and uh
thank you representative uh silver for
uh taking my question
I'm I'm sorry uh Devin
um uh maybe this is a naive question but
is it possible is it reasonable or
possible or should we even try to
separate out what is an individual tax
as opposed to the IND taxes on on
businesses and corporations that's just
a question and I don't know that there's
an answer to that and I uh
uh that's that's my question
as far as uh breaking out what this bill
does to certain entities is that what
your question is uh let me be um Let me
clarify would it be a in your opinion a
a different bill or a
two it would be a different build would
it be a better Bill to or not to have a
bill for uh doing this for individuals
and have a bill for doing this for uh
businesses
two separate instead of rolling this
into one that's something that I would
have to consult with our with some other
folks in our department as far as the
constitutionality of that goes and as
well as the feasibility of that I'd have
to give back to the committee on that
but I definitely will
thank you very much thank you for your
time no problem
s
we're going to break more uh thank you
Mr chairman members of the committee and
thank you for working uh with me through
my technical difficulties
um in this new world we're living in uh
for the record my name is Greg Moore I
am the state director with Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire and I'm
here today to offer Americans for
Prosperity New Hampshire's full support
for the goal of phasing out the interest
in dividends tax as I'm sure everyone
knows May and New Hampshire are fond of
saying that we don't have an income tax
and while it's true that the state
doesn't generally tax wages uh of course
as this committee knows granted stated
our tax on interest and dividends income
moreover in recent years dra has
indicated that the majority of IND tax
filers are seniors many of them many of
whom are taxing their retirement
instruments like annuities
unfortunately this has had the effect of
motivating many of these seniors to
become residents of states that don't
tax US income like Florida I personally
know a number of seniors who have left
New Hampshire as a direct result of this
tax and when they declare residency in
another state it follows a predictable
pattern that the mid net worth retirees
leave entirely while a high net worth
individuals simply spend more than half
their year in another state and keep
their homes here while they come from
late spring to early fall and the
economic impact of losing these
individuals is substantial not only do
they do they not spend their money here
to grow our economy they're also not
investing here which undermines future
successful businesses from taking root
it certainly wasn't lost on me when
during the worst of pandemic for those
States New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
and New Jersey governor Murphy use their
coveted press conferences to beg High
net worth individuals not to abandon
those States because they said the
economic impact would be in their words
devastating and yet here in New
Hampshire we have a vehicle that takes
these folks right out of our state
and I'd like to offer the committee a
concrete example to drive home the point
as a former member of the House our a
former member of the House in fact
someone who served with the chair and
the vice chair in the Rock and Camp
County delegation The Honorable Will
Smith who made abundantly clear that he
changed his residency from New Hampshire
to Florida exclusively to avoid paying
this tax now we'll still still spends
time here at his home in Newcastle for
about five months a year but that's down
from the nine months he would used to
spend here before before he moved as a
result of the IND tax while the loss of
additional uh lost the addition to the
economy he would have added over those
additional four months is real there's a
bigger issue when will was a full-time
New Hampshire resident he was involved
in Angel Investing here however now that
he's a floral resident he no longer is
involved in that area
so losing four months from Will has a
magnified economic impact on our state
and that's just one example I have
several other individuals I know who
have stories just like Wills I also have
stories that over our middle middle
class individuals who are activists of
ours who simply packed up and left for
good as a result of this tax what's most
personally impactful is when they asked
for contact information from an AFP
chapter in States like Florida Texas or
Arizona where they're moving so that
they can still stay involved but they
wish that they could have stayed here
have you even had one of our activists
move to Alaska over this tax which is
hardly where I suppose I'd want to spend
my uh retirement the point here is that
losing these folks is not good for our
economy period the good news is that we
have an example of a state that phased
out its IND tax to understand its impact
Tennessee as of this past New Year's day
did away with its Hall income tax which
was its own IND tax and like us
Tennessee also doesn't tax wages the
beacon Center of Tennessee a policy
Think Tank has been tracking the effect
of the phase out of the whole income tax
over time their research has shown that
the estimated anticipated overall
revenue losses from phasing out this tax
have not materialized in the state
stands in a stronger position
economically as a result
so while a static analysis of the
reduction Revenue will seem significant
it's also important to balance that
against the potential economic growth
which can also benefit State revenues
that's why we fully support the the idea
of the phase out of a 90 tax Not only
would it make New Hampshire a truly
income tax free but it would add new
unexpected economic growth to our state
now while we fully support the phase out
of the IND text we would do it
differently than the manner included in
House Bill 568 instead of increasing
exemptions we would suggest a matter
similar to House Bill 529 which came to
this Committee in 2017 sponsored by
representative Ken Weiler that bill
gradually reduced the int tax rate which
we believe is a better phase out
strategy and one that matches how
Tennessee phased out its Hall income tax
the reason why we prefer that route is
because in our view the best tax reform
strategy is to keep the base as broad as
possible until and to reduce rates well
the uh Hospital 568 shrinks the base and
keeps the rates at a higher level
moreover we are concerned about that if
in 2025 the state legislature would have
choose to stop the phase out then the
reduction in the base of the tax as a
result of the increase in the exemption
could leave the state vulnerable to
litigation the state no longer has a
broadly based IND tax and puts us in a
constitutional Jeopardy similar to the
BPT litigation from the late 80s and
early 90s
it is for that reason we support the
phase out similar to House Bill 529 from
two legislatures ago thank you for the
opportunity to testify here today and
I'd be happy to answer any questions and
and I have a cold it is not the
coronavirus so thank you thank you
members of the committee
thank you Greg questions
here so then we will
go Dan McGuire
representing the member of the public
and also the Granite State taxpayers
Association who's in support of the bill
in July
thank you very much Mr chairman may I be
permitted to testify via video I did put
my tie on this morning
thank you
Mr chair would you like me to
um
yes
you should be
there I am
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire and today I'm
representing Granite State taxpayers
I've been a member of the board for over
10 years
um
we're in support of this bill
um reduce the interest in dividends tax
no
hold on a second
[Music]
my cell phone is muted but my phone is
not
um so we're in support of this bill to
eliminate the interest and dividends tax
um because in our opinion and in my
opinion this is the worst tax that we
have the most destructive to our economy
um of all the ones you know the BPT the
other taxes and so on
in general
attacks uh discourages whatever it is
that's being taxed the activity or the
item or what have you and and sometimes
that's explicit because things like
these attacks on Tobacco we explicit in
other syntaxes we explicitly want less
of what a less tobacco use uh less
liquor use Etc because they're they're
um distracted to the public health and
so it's it's very effective the high tax
on cigarettes
um causes fewer people to smoke people
to smoke less Etc
which is which but this tax the interest
in dividends tax is a tax on savings
and savings is the most
um
important thing for the economy to move
forward because savings creates Capital
it creates businesses it creates
machines it creates innovation
and that is how the economy gets better
year after year
and and it's an improving and common
economy which helps the citizens of New
Hampshire which which
um improves their lives
um makes one year better than the next
and so on why was 2020 such a horrible
year right 2019 was a very fine year
2020 was horrible because it wasn't as
good as 2019.
and so for for our
General
um well-being and happiness
we need an improvement
economy what definition
um today is better than yesterday
and so
um it's the interest in dividends tax or
it's savings really which create a
better tomorrow than today and so um
it's it's it needs to be eliminated
um if if there's any tax you cut this is
the one that should be cut thank you Mr
chairman I'm happy to answer questions
thank you Mr McGuire
honorable employer
any questions
so then we will go to
Melissa robs
from the dra staff who committee
hi Mr chair members of the committee
um I am all set I was just here to
support Devin Roderick if needed so I
think he has covered everything that
needs to be said from the dra
all right
thank you
and everybody else voices that testify
all right
we do have a number that have signed up
Senator Daniels signed up for supports
all right
and support
Nicole
I'm sorry I called importantly
the Republicans find that opposed
representative
um
[Music]
Thomas and support
the current platform
member of the public housing
represented
and then Alvin C
remember the public and support
more other questions
yes thank you Mr chairman uh I just have
to say I'm having a very hard time uh
understanding you uh uh and I don't know
if it's my side or it's a microphone
issue or when uh it seems to be kind of
cutting in and out uh faint so I could
not hear clearly all the names of the
people that uh uh signed in so I I would
I think we have a technical issue and I
would uh urge the staff to help us
correct that so we can all hear clearly
uh your comments thank you
okay and then for the members of the
committee
[Music]
a representative major I have a question
representative
yeah I'm sorry I should have brought
this up earlier but when representative
when Mr Moore from if he was testifying
it seems that he was reading a statement
well that statement be
sent to us
okay thank you
[Music]
um
you need to unmute
unmute yourself
you're talking about me Jenny yes okay
yes um are you speaking with your mask
on
is that why you sound so muffled no I've
taken the mask off
is that still muffled maybe you can lift
the microphone up just a little bit so
it's important
okay is this better
yes
I have all kinds of helpers here to help
[Music]
representative Tucker
unmute
all right
uh hints you can just press this
I just wanted to say that I had arrived
late
but I'm here
okay noted thank you
okay and the same for me
and represent you early
yeah I remember yesterday I mentioned uh
that they had some problems uh in the
committee rooms with uh in Commerce
across the hall well or upstairs across
the hall
um
that's the same kind of issue they're
having here that the table mics don't
seem to be picking up uh as
um efficiently as they could and also a
little hack you don't have to upload
yourself all you have to
should we do a test for the table mics
to see if we can hear us but yeah all
you have to do is press the space bar
and it'll unmute you temporarily let's
try something different
they just moved the table my closet yeah
a little bit closer do I need to take it
away no or let's check
how is that
much better
representative major there is an
attendee that's on a telephone with
their hand up shall I give them
permission to talk
yes
and who is that that's what we're trying
to figure out
I believe it is uh Chris Christensen
um
but the caller needs to press star 6 to
unmute themselves
well get these bugs worked out
eventually
the name is the person on the telephone
they've just unmuted and I believe it
may be Chris Christensen but we'll need
that to be verified
yes this is Chris Christensen
yes
thank you Mr chairman
uh I think you have my letter oh I'm
Chris Christensen representing myself
I'm from Merrimack New Hampshire
the
gist of my testimonies in the letter
that you've already received I'll try
not to repeat that I agree
wholeheartedly with representative
silber's comments about this I would
like to add
one
set of circumstances that I
think is pretty ironic actually and that
is that this interest in dividends tax
started many years ago
with an exemption
for New Hampshire savings institutions
and Vermont uh
and the intent was to bring more money
into the banking system in New Hampshire
and I think for a time it was successful
in the 80s mag started doing National
mergers and that exemption was seen as a
Restraint of trade and instead of
eliminating the tax completely it was
extended to all interests and dividends
seemed like a good idea at the time I
guess
but now we've heard testimony and I have
personal experience with friends in the
state
that it is chasing people out of the
state they're leaving and going to
Florida or wherever it might be to avoid
this particular tax and sometimes to
avoid some cold weather I guess
in the meantime
I think we've done a good job bringing
some money into the state
with such things as
tax exemptions
for New Hampshire trust and
I think if we're going to be a complete
picture that eliminating the interest in
dividends tax would continue in that
direction and attract more money into
the state rather than chasing it out
other than that I I think everything
else has been said by others and I'm
willing to accept any questions
I hope you'll vote ought to pass
exactly for your testimony
any questions
I do not see the raised hands
my middle participants here
so
I'm going to close the public hearing on
hustle 568 National transgen
okay I'm going to open the public
hearing House Bill 210 FN
exemption under the interest and
dividend tax and decreasing the total
amount of research and development
credits against the business taxes
Prime sponsor representative Lang
representative language
yes thank you Mr chair thank you I'm not
sure if they can hear me with the mic
Loops but you can take the mic over to
that desk over there and
sorry
[Music]
Mr chairman and thank you I'm glad to be
back in front of ways of things I just
said here earlier it's my second most
favorite committee because now I'm a
chair fishing game I think that has to
be my primary committee but thank you
for having me back I appreciate uh being
able to speak on this this important
bill this bill does two basic things it
allows New Hampshire citizens to keep
their money
and it requires New Hampshire businesses
not the other Tax Services that we're
giving them right now for tax credit
um the second part of this bill
basically creates a liability on first
part of this bill in other words we're
giving up businesses an increased tax
credit then someone has to pay for that
budget and that comes from people who
pay taxes like people who paid interest
in giving that stats what I tried to do
here because having served two terms on
this community one of the things I used
to dislike which I think maybe with a a
reduction bill is they didn't explain
how they're going to pay for the hole in
the budget that they were created this
bill seeks to do that it Nets out the
difference so the as you see from the
fiscal note part one of this bill that
increased the exceptions for people who
are subject to the dividend stocks as a
rough cost of about five million dollars
um the second half of this bill which
reduces the
research and development tax credit
reduces that by five million dollars
getting out of zero difference in our
income so we're not creating a budget
deficit our budget pull uh in this bill
of any significance
um
one thing I will I will say again having
Services community
and and dra both in on this on this bill
speaking
um
every time you ask for the direct
correlation of a tax credit to
um State benefit
on this particular one usually what we
hear is it's a checkbox when businesses
are coming into the state one of the
questions they always ask is does the
state have a research development tax
rate yes or no it's a checkbox on a form
not how much it is but merely do you
have one this bill still keeps that
check box checked to reduce the
different interest the research
development tax credit from seven
million dollars back to 2 million
dollars
this was originally when the research
development tax credit was implemented
by staff by law by a bill it was
implemented at two million dollars
through a budget negotiation
into one of the house bill twos all of a
sudden five million dollars appeared on
Research development tax credit and the
cow was increased instead
which is not the proper way of doing
budgeting and billing and shipping them
back someone wants to bring it back up
to seven million dollars
in the profitability and not through a
budget deal that was made in House Bill
too so if this bill also seeks to fix
the contestants that was done and ran
for that business subsidy in a tax
credit
um
I'm happy to take questions I know
you're gonna have Bea and probably era
probably Bia
[Music]
yes I will
Mr chair is the Bia going to speak today
or not they are then I'll hold my
question until then thank you
representative
[Music]
yes thank you Mr chairman
um thank you representative Lang for
taking my question
um what you're proposing on the face of
it seems to make sense I guess my
question would be based on the testimony
we heard on the previous Bill
eliminating the interest in dividends
tax
um
but many of those arguments were that
we're losing a lot of
um
High income investors or high you know
people who are benefiting from they're
moving to Florida to avoid the tax so if
if you go from a 2400 exemption to a 3
500 exemption is that really going to
stop
um you know what we heard previously
were a lot of these uh people are
moving to Florida and other states
so again
for investors right we're increasing
that exemption and the threshold before
you have to pay this tax and so the
smaller investors would become now no
longer subject to the Caps you know to
keep their money larger investors are
still subject to the taxes
thank you
[Music]
so if you do the next testifying would
be
the jewelry the Mars
a member of the public and the pausing
the bill
would you like that
if you not see
I do not see
oh Julie Demers but it looks like the
New Hampshire Tech Alliance which is
um
Mr mers's
organization has raised their hand
um
I've just allowed them to talk please
um unmute yourself
hi thank you so much um can everyone
hear me okay
yes
thank you and thank you all for your
time today
um so as it was noted my name is Julie
Demars and I'm here on behalf of the New
Hampshire Tech Alliance
um the tech Alliance is the largest
member driven technology Association in
the state we support research Innovation
economic and Workforce Development
efforts that have helped New Hampshire
become a national leader in
technology-based industrial and
development and entrepreneurism
our organization Works to promote and
grow our Tech sector by reducing
barriers to growth and finding better
ways to access capital and the human
resources needed to support the New
Hampshire economy in years like this and
Beyond
so our government Affairs efforts which
is a comprehensive team representative
of our membership focus on ensuring that
the regulatory structure is as business
friendly as possible and that growth
incentives are in place to serve our
members therefore today we're standing
in opposition to this bill we recognize
that a healthy r d tax credit is a
critical component of a larger effort to
better the business climate for New
Hampshire high-tech companies and it is
a key component in attracting high-tech
businesses I would argue that it's not
just a box to check
a cut to the existing credit Will impede
our ability to continue to grow the tech
sector in New Hampshire so Tech stands
alongside Advanced manufacturing as one
of the leading drivers of our economy so
the technology sector alone contributed
10.9 billion or 13.7 percent of the
state's GDP
um in 2019 and jobs in this sector pay
higher wages and Export products from
the state to other areas
in the world so this is effectively
transferring outside money into the
state's economy these sectors provide
Healthy Living wages to New Hampshire
individuals and their families
so you're looking at technology
companies whose media and Tech
occupation wages continue to increase
and they're 85 percent higher than New
Hampshire's median State wages so that's
continuing to grow that's up from 80 in
2018. so I understand the argument that
we want New Hampshire citizens to keep
their money but this is at the expense
of the com companies that are bringing
these really high paying jobs with
healthy wages and although New Hampshire
arguably does have a very high quality
of life it also has one of the highest
tax business tax rates in the nation our
current r d tax credit program supports
the growth in the tech sector it allows
us to remain competitive in the global
marketplace with um especially in this
environment with remote workforces being
increasingly more accepted we're
Fielding calls every week of technology
companies that are looking to move here
and they have an interest in New
Hampshire I'm just asking that we do not
give these companies a reason in to look
to other states that have more
attractive r d tax credits lower energy
costs more favorable environmental and
labor regulations and and lower business
taxes I'm going to reiterate again that
it was mentioned that this is just a box
to check it's really not these companies
are comparing Apples to Apples and it
could be the make or break between a
company coming here bringing high-paying
jobs
um or going elsewhere so in 2018 I think
there was an interest in understanding
the impact of this and I'm sure you have
this information but in 2018 the first
year that that tax credit was available
you had 71 companies reporting more than
112 million of qualified research and
development related wages that it
engaged and applied for that credit in
2020 that that increased to 230
companies so companies are taking
advantage of this so our membership
specifically which ranges from small
startups to large companies that conduct
Commerce both nationally and globally
um benefits from a healthy r d tax
credit program so ultimately we feel
that a change to the existing
um r d tax credit would be a huge step
backwards for our membership the the
sector and the state overall when you're
looking at the companies that are
looking to grow here and what we want
New Hampshire to be
about four or five years down the road
so thank you I I appreciate the time
today and I'd be open to any questions
here we have a question
[Music]
thank you thank you Mr chairman uh Mr
Merz on I was the uh chair at the time
that we set up the r d on tax credit it
is from
2009 I believe maybe eight eight
on and
at that time it was meant as a million
on and it got raised to 2 million and
then all of a sudden to 7 million
because uh so many more companies wanted
to use it but everybody that uh uses
this Credit First has to take the
Federal Credit and we have never been
given information that would allow us to
understand what percentage of the
federal tax credit is what they are
getting from the state one since the
state really can't afford very much
money for things like this and it goes
on your local property tax if we cut our
taxes at the state level too much
thank you
thank you you have information on this
on when someone gets the federal tax
credit and then they turn around and get
the New Hampshire tax credit what what
is the ratio in terms of money acquired
I do not have that information but I
just made a note um to have that be a
talking point and have our government
Affairs committee and also our executive
committee look into seeing if this can
be information that we could actively
gather for future reference
thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
nurse for testifying with us today uh in
your testimony you uh you alluded to a
statistics statistics from other states
uh on this r d do you have any
information on those other states that
you were talking about so that we can
have a comparison to their their rights
as a comparison to ours
I have it anecdotally but if that would
be helpful for you to see I think that
could be something we could pull
together thank you
any further questions
and none
we will go to
Dan McGuire
who supports
okay you'll be good
okay then why
thank you very much Mr chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Dan McGuire I'm from Epsom
and I'm a member of the board of Granite
State taxpayers
um
I'm previously on the on the previous
Bill uh testified why we think the
um interest in dividends tax should be
reduced if and eliminate ideally
eliminated
um but I also am in favor or we are also
in favor of the other half of this bill
which is reducing or eliminating
research and development tax credit
now I personally am an angel investor
and frequently invest in Tech startups
and so you might think that I've gone in
favor of the research and development
tax credits but
I've heard in any meeting where we
consider
um investing in a in a tech company that
this is any kind of issue
um or that any kind of a benefit or
anything like that
is exactly correct and let me expand her
point
if you go into this bill and look at the
RSA that has the research and
development tax credit it refers to a
section of the U.S tax code and if you
go search for that and and read who is
actually getting the credit the
definition of this credit because we
just give some fraction of the Federal
Credit to to New Hampshire companies so
we we're adding on to the Federal Credit
you will find that this is not a simple
you know you did so much research last
year so we're going to give you a
fraction of it back
um this is not based on just last year's
activity
definition of the research Credit in
um in federal tax law is based on uh
it's a very complicated formula but it
has to do with you know what did you do
since 1981 how much research have you
done in the past Etc so so in my opinion
what's what it really does is benefit
companies that were small uh at in you
know 20 30 years ago such as Microsoft
Apple Intel Etc they're the ones getting
the bulk of this of this credit
um it's not about how much research did
you do last year and therefore if you're
increasing it you're going to get a
better you know pay less tax this year
so so my point is it's not good to
distort the tax code in this way and and
say that somehow a high-tech company is
better than some other kind of company
but also it
it's code that's that's favoring
specific large companies
um as opposed to to other companies in
the same business so
um
we are in very much in favor of as I
said reducing or eliminating uh this
particular tax credit it is not a it's
not what you think it is just based on
the name of it thank you very much Mr
chairman
questions
um
[Music]
uh this is more of a question for the
chair uh because of um The Honorable uh
Mr McGuire uh his testimony kind of cut
out a little bit is there going to be a
written testimony submitted from him
I'd be happy to do that
um thank you Mr Barr we you just cut out
just a little bit and I think that there
may have been some important pieces that
we might have missed
no problem my home internet is not the
best
thank you Mr chairman
I do not see anybody's hands so then
I do see one representative oh
with his handout
I guess it went away this is John
representative jinigian
um I have a question for Mr McGuire
um I guess in considering your I'm
someone who spent 25 years in high tech
uh not necessarily as an investor more
as a participant but as you're looking
at companies
it seems to me counterintuitive that I
mean I can see where there's certain
companies of certain sizes that uh you
know if you're a one or two person
startup the seven million exemption
isn't going to help you that much but if
you are large enough
that you know I don't know what that
number would be 10 15 employees 20
employees
um 30 employees wear that 7 million
makes a huge difference in your r d
budget
um I guess my concern would be are we
losing chances for Innovation because
while you're saying large companies
um you know it's just a benefit for them
these mid-size small to mid-sized
companies are we possibly losing
opportunities for future Innovation
which could lead to economic growth
thank you thank you for the question
representative I think you'll find that
well seven million sounds like a
significant number
um this is being spread over I don't
know 50 to 100 companies you could ask
the dra specifically how many companies
um take advantage of this but now you're
talking about if it were a hundred
companies at seventy thousand dollars
per company and seventy thousand dollars
um for a company like Microsoft is a
nothing right so
um I don't think it is a significant uh
factor in where they where they want to
be and and where they want to do
business and and so on uh
um it's much more is the ability of
these that's a huge part of you know
high-tech industry as to
um where where you locate
um and you know we're somewhat of a
subsidiary of the Boston area so which
is a hotbed of high-tech
and so that's part of it
follow up Mr chairman
um
so if we look at the Boston area do you
know what the
uh in Massachusetts what they're
offering for any for an exemption on r d
okay thank you
okay
there is one that can be
wrong
I was just asking Jen about this do we
do we need to find out who it is
g-t-h-a-l
with a hand up
representative major if you want to
continue with your
um
preferred list or order of calling on
speakers you could call on others at the
end
okay thank you Jen
I'm only
responding to hands up to questions at
this point in time next breaker
is Dave Gervais representing the
business and industry Association
and he's opposing the bill
David
thank you Mr chair and members of the
House Ways and Means Committee I trust
everyone can hear me okay
yes for the record my name is Dave Juve
I'm a senior vice president for public
policy at the business and industry
Association we are a New Hampshire based
Statewide Chamber of Commerce with
approximately 400 members businesses of
all sizes from the state's largest
companies down to single sole owner
operators I appreciate the opportunity
to testify in opposition to House Bill
210 and the opportunity to explain why
this would be a
really unfortunate move for for the
State of New Hampshire to take I first
want to comment on a couple of things
from previous testifiers to I hope
um clear up what may be some
misunderstandings the first was
representative
said that the seven million dollars
which the state is investing in research
and development tax credits was uh in
inappropriate budget process or an
inappropriate legislative process and I
think what he meant by that was there
was not a bill that originated in the
house increasing the state investment to
7 million it was added to the state
budget negotiations in the Senate but
that bill has all budget bills to come
back to the house for concurrence or
non-concurrence in this case the house
non-concurred which they almost always
do and requested a committee of
conference and at that point that was
the opportunity for the house to
question this uh increase in in the
state investment or uh if if they felt
it was that critical to non-concur on
the budget but but it didn't even come
up in the discussion so I want to make
sure Committee Member understand that
the increase in seven million wasn't the
result of a specific bill but there was
nothing improper about the budgeting
process that was undertaken
I'd also like to comment on the check
box and the representatives correct if
we have a research and development tax
credit even at a de minimis amount there
will be a box that will be checked but I
can assure you that uh the program
itself and that box will become a
laughing stock because if you reduce the
state investment to 2 million based on
the number of companies that applied in
uh fiscal year 2020 they'll be getting a
less than 10 cents on the dollar for
what they are eligible for under the
research and development tax credit
program
I'd also like to address a couple of
other things
um and I worked with with representative
Almy back in 2007 the 2007 session where
this bill passed it was it was
implemented in 2008 that was the first
year that companies could take advantage
of it and we worked closely together on
it and one of the things we worked on
that hasn't been brought up was the
original
um language for the bill was the tax
credit only applied to business profits
taxpayers but we realized early on that
our intent uh was that this also be
available for for smaller companies that
that may not be profitable and are there
five therefore only paying the business
Enterprise tax and that was added to the
bill and that exists in the law to this
day we also did some other things to
make sure that smaller companies could
take advantage of it and that is we
capped the total amount of credit that
would be given out in any uh given tax
year to a maximum of fifty thousand
dollars per company and in fact the uh
information from the Department of
Revenue Administration on the tax
research and development tax credit
summary which I did uh submit to the
committee via email this morning so I'm
hoping all committee members will have a
chance to review it
um
over 230 New Hampshire companies applied
for the credit for fiscal year or for uh
tax year 2020 so it's more than double
uh the hundred dollars at a previous or
the 100 companies that are previous
testifier
um said it's 230 companies and by the
way that is increased from the first
year of the program from 71 companies so
clearly something is going on either
there are more companies doing research
and development which uh this tax credit
is meant to
encourage or somehow over the years more
companies have heard about it which if
if they have uh good accountants they
should have heard about it in 2008 but
in any event of of those 230 companies
uh 94 of the companies received
requested less than the fifty thousand
dollars in and that's a good indicator
that smaller companies are also taking
advantage of this research and
development tax credit and by the way
one of those smaller companies is uh
graphic cast which is in Jaffrey I also
included in the email this morning a
recent uh op-ed piece by Val zanchuk
who's the president of graphic cast he
is someone who takes advantage of the
research and development tax credit in
his op-ed says why graphic cast has 23
employees so they are not by any stretch
of the imagination a large high-tech or
large uh manufacturing company but it is
critical for them
um just a couple of other things
um
why does the state do this well one
reason is that 33 other states around
the country uh have research and
development tax credits so this is not
exactly an unusual thing and but it is
something that New Hampshire needs to be
aware of in terms of recruiting
companies uh to the state and wanting
companies who are already here to expand
their operations
um but there's more than that uh it is
in a compelling State interest to uh
encourage and Foster manufacturing and
high technology jobs I
um have a document here from our state
uh Department of Employment Security
every year they track average wages and
for the entire State uh the average
weekly wage for private sector jobs is
one thousand one hundred and forty five
that's for uh 2019 which is the most
recent year they have data for
1145 dollars per week
um for private sector employment in New
Hampshire
in manufacturing they break it out by
economic sectors and Manufacturing the
average weekly wage is one thousand four
hundred and three dollars
um roughly
250 dollars more uh roughly and if you
look at chemical manufacturing they're
one thousand six hundred dollars a week
and if you look at computer and
electronic product manufacturing they're
one thousand nine hundred dollars a week
so not only are these types of companies
providing high-wage jobs which benefits
the economy because those wages get
plowed back into the economy
um but they also benefit the state
because as you all know the business
Enterprise tax is is is
um uh
uh almost entirely based on company
compensation so if a company is is
paying out more in compensation their
business Enterprise tax payments will be
higher to the state so there is a
compelling interest why I'm not
suggesting one company is better than
the other one economic sector is better
than the other uh one job is better than
the other but there are differences and
uh it's clear that it is in the state's
best interest to maintain a healthy
manufacturing and high-tech economy and
then finally I want to address uh the
the issue of this five million dollars
now I guess I should state that Bia does
not have a position on increasing
exemptions for the interest in dividends
tax or eliminating it entirely we leave
that up to the wisdom of the legislature
I would suggest you don't need to rob
from one of the state's most successful
Economic Development programs to fund
that uh in using the department of
administrative services
um most recent Revenue Focus which is
for December of 2020 or uh FY 2021 but
December of 2020 uh they say that the
state in terms of business profits tax
and business Enterprise tax is running
in excess of 65 million dollars that's
65 million dollars higher than what
budgeted projections were for so let's
not pretend we can't find five million
dollars somewhere if the state uh wants
to to increase exemptions or or or
eliminate the IND tax uh uh in its
entirety you don't need to a
successful economic development program
one of the few that the state of New
Hampshire offers in order to do that uh
thank you Mr chair I would be happy to
address any questions
questions or Representatives chamber
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Goulet
uh a question
does the Bia have a statistical number
of the new products or improvements to
products or jobs or salary increases
that are directly related
to the last 12 years of research and
development tax credits
uh the answer to that question is no and
part of the reason why is the Bia nor
anyone else outside of the Department of
Revenue Administration knows who the
companies are I know a few within the
Bia membership because they've expressed
some concern about uh the research and
development tax credit being rolled back
as this bill would would uh purport to
do in fact the committee heard from two
two members valzan Chuck and Tom white
from New England wire who spoke about
the research and development tax credit
when you had your economic briefing
several weeks ago but but specifically
your question we don't have any way to
track that
um because we don't know who who all the
companies are I can tell you that uh in
terms of employment since the tax was
implemented in 2008 uh New Hampshire
qualified raises New Hampshire qualified
wages those that qualified for the
research and development tax credit Rose
from 112 million per year to over
510 million now over a half a billion
dollars that's a pretty significant
increase over a 12-year period of time
and I would suggest that it has
increased every year and those first
years 2008 2009 and into 2010 you will
remember was
um
the uh the Great Recession so even in
the Great Recession there was increased
uh usage of r d tax credits
thank you sir
thank you Mr chairman
Dave on
we we have been on some something
like a reverse waterfall on this this uh
tax credit it was started at 1 million
in order to
to be able
to check that box and there were not
that many people using it at the
beginning because we were targeting
on new companies we were targeting young
companies the only way we could do it
was to keep the amount of money
available low per capita we we did cap
it as you said and but we had to use the
federal tax credit because
administratively the state couldn't have
handled anything else
on but when it was doubled to 2 million
because too many people were starting to
use it and they were only getting 25 000
each uh because it's prorated on they on
the number Grow Again to take care of
the 2 million and we were back down to
2025 each I think it was 17 each the
last year on and they put 5 million more
in it and it's been growing since then
it's under
000 on
Sunday if we keep this up and you Bia is
the one that that started that has been
asking for this on we're going to have a
tax credit that's worth 50 million
dollars or something like that so how do
we avoid that without on going against
the the principle of the Constitution
that on we have to treat everybody
equally
um thank you representative almi for the
question I have to confess my memory on
this is a little different than yours
um the the original language of the bill
there was no cap at all
and uh in house Ways and Means Committee
uh there was significant concern about
well how do we know what the uh fiscal
impact will be how do we know how many
people will be taking these credits and
the answer was we didn't know nor could
we forecast because it had never existed
before or at least hadn't existed since
the the mid-1990s and so the decision
was made uh first of all that we need to
somehow uh create a cap to make sure the
state is not exposed you know in a way
that would be detrimental to the budget
and then the decision and this was
really uh negotiation and pulling a
number out of the air was to have it at
a million dollars per year so we could
see what the
um
interest and and usage of the r d tax
credit was and we all agreed to that it
was it was done by Design
um as you've noted over the years that's
increased from uh one million per year
to the current 7 million per year and
and by the way I would say at the 1
million per year companies that applied
in 2008 were only getting 41 of their
requests because of the 1 million dollar
cap when it was increased to seven
million dollars in 2017 uh companies
were now getting 92 percent of their
requests so still not a hundred percent
but close that has gone down since 2017
and companies are now as of 2020
receiving 76 percent
um and I guess the response my response
to your question would be
um
it's really a matter of State policy and
what keeps it from going up to 50
million is is that the state has this
cap that that uh they won't go beyond
and then it's a state decision if how
closely they want that cap to match uh
demand for the r d tax credit right now
they're matching at 75 cents on the
dollar
um if anything we would argue that it
might be appropriate to increase uh the
cap it hasn't been increased since 2017
but we're not asking for that this year
but you know everyone knows this is an
unusual time in in our country and in
the state in the budgeting process is
going to be difficult as it is we're not
asking for an increase but we are
certainly opposing any type of decrease
and then of course any further questions
who's talking
or push your space bar and talk and hold
up yep sorry uh I don't have a question
for the president speaker but my
question is for representative Lang it's
a simple question
on page one
line 18 and 19
where it says exemptions each taxpayer
shall have the following exemptions
representative
right now
can you hear me Mr Speaker
I mean Mr chairman representative
Elliott replying doesn't happen to be
uh in the room with us right now all
right maybe you know then the answer on
line 19 the income of thirty five
hundred dollars it doesn't say how long
that is and the previous speaker
mentioned that the average per week is
1145 dollars a week which comes to
almost sixty thousand dollars so I don't
understand line 19 where it says income
of thirty five hundred dollars how long
is that for does anybody know
and how can you live on that that's one
year Bob
that's for one year
yeah
on representative Elliott that's only
the interest in dividends
oh okay that's
that that's not their total income
that's just on the dividend okay thank
you very much
I don't see any other raised fans right
now if there is
[Music]
continue
since it was more about raised hands and
we'll go to Devin Radford from the dra
um
say a few words
seven
thank you chairman members of the
committee this is Devin Roderick again
financial analysis of the New Hampshire
Department of Revenue tax policy
legislative analysis group testifying
women's Melissa Rollins could you
promote or unmute her as well at this
time
foreign
if you could if you could unmute both of
us that'd be great thank you I'm a muted
Devin thank you so
HP 210 Section 1 would increase the
filing threshold from 24 to 3500 in
section 2 it increases the additional
exemptions of being blind disabled or 65
years of age or older including spouses
from 1200 to 1750. these two sections
would take effect January 1st 2022
and apply to tax years ending on or
after December 31st 2022.
we've applied these changes to tax your
2018 data
and it would have resulted in a decrease
in revenue of about 5.1 million
lastly is important to note that this
does not take into account any
overpayments or credits that are on file
much like the previous bill
section three of the proposed
legislation as previously explained
decreases the aggregate amount that we
can award for the r d taxpayer program
from 7 million Down 2 million
um for any fiscal year effective July
1st 2021 this would result in an
increase
of up to 5 million state general and
education trust fund revenues
the dra cannot determine the potential
increase in Revenue in future years
because it has no way of knowing the
extent to which they would use these
previously awarded r d tax credits
because it's important to note that the
r d tax credit New Hampshire as a
basically a five-year carry forward
they're able to use that r d tax credit
toward business liability within the
five subsequent taxable periods beyond
the period which it's earned
if you have any other any questions I'll
be happy to answer them
okay
does the committee have any questions
on
Devin and Melissa on two things one of
them could you give us a historical list
of the numbers that got the tax credit
since it began per year and how much
they got each time of that 50
000 cap yes that's actually provided in
the New Hampshire Department of Revenue
research development tax credit summary
women happy to forward that along to the
members of the committee I believe Mr
Juve did mention the email that this
morning as well but we can go ahead and
report that to you
um if it's in his email I didn't have a
chance to look at it yet I had another
meeting that's no problem and just to
confirm I'll uh I believe all the
information he gave you off that sharp
is accurate when you see that chart
um just note that the the top of the
chart is obviously the first year of the
program and if you were to look to the
far right of that chart it shows a
percentage of requested value that's
actually awarded so the r d tax credit
is based on 10 percent of qualified
wages to New Hampshire
capped at fifty thousand
or prorated whichever is lesser of the
three every year the program has
previously stated the requested amounts
that exceeded the amount of the
Department of Revenue award so every
year there's a proration that's applied
equally across all applicants those
percentages are listed in the far right
of the chart
thank you the other question was I
wasn't able to be here for the last bill
but in the last bill you calculated on
the base of tax year
on 19. and for this one you use tax year
18.
yeah and for another one I think it was
tax year 20 so
for these for these two IND bills that
was a timing thing of when we when we
received the fiscal when we completed it
I did take a look at the applied this
bill to tax your 2019 liability and the
difference was minimal was about 400 000
difference on the IND portion of this
bill
so the number the overall impact did not
change very much with this depending on
which tattoo you applied it to
normally I I guess the other bill that
you mentioned that tax your 20 but we
don't have complete data for tax year 20
yet so in this particular instance I
would not have used that for IND
analysis
thank you no problem
any further questions
saying
any questions
then on the blue sheet
posing
the bill is the Nicole pottery
member of the public
also a Liz tantarelli
a member of the public
supported the bills Senator Reagan
opposing as well
nunchuck
who
referred today in testimony he runs a
small company
less than 25 employees
the Bob greens
supports the bill
and Tina Harley supports the bill
can representative Wilder
supports the bill actually blocked three
Representatives
member of the public Eric rothburn
closes the bill
and Tom Pulaski
represent
supports the bill
anybody else wishes
support
or oppose the bill
I've seen nobody running
to do that so I'm going to pause the
Karen Hospital 210
we're running about 25 minutes behind
so we'll go right into Hospital 353.
this is an act establishing incredibness
RSA 77 for tax paid or an income subject
for taxation in another state
he has he has joined us Mr chairman so
he will introduce uh virtually
representative okay representative
put him on John good morning
good morning this is representative
Daryl Abbas I uh represent a Rockingham
County District 8. I wanted to thank the
members of the committee for all right
hearing me today uh the reason this bill
I put this bill forward is so in in S
Corp in Massachusetts that operates
solely in Massachusetts
uh what is occurring
is it if you are a resident of New
Hampshire
and even though you're operating solely
in Massachusetts you are paying a double
tax on the income earned through being
paid to dividends a dividend as a
shareholder of the corporation
even if the that S Corp operates solely
in Massachusetts
and all the work is performed there but
you just happen to reside in New
Hampshire
now the problem occurs is that and why
that's happening is in Massachusetts the
dividend that is paid
they are classifying that as
an income tax so it's being it's
categorized as an individual income tax
tax at the same rate and just put into
uh when you file your tax that's what it
falls under
because in New Hampshire we don't have
an income tax and I pray to God we never
do
we are class New Hampshire we classify
that as a dividends tax so what is
happening is that normally they were
both in income tax they would be an
offset
from between the states but we are not
New Hampshire is not offering that
offset or that credit because they're
calling it something different
I looked I've always looked at that it's
When in Rome if you're earning it in
Rome it should be taxed under homes law
so if you're operating solely in
Massachusetts and all the works done
there you just happen to have a New
Hampshire address
and that's where you reside
it shouldn't be called something
different by New Hampshire so
it's been well set by
Supreme the Supreme Court on more than
one occasion at a double taxation is
unconstitutional and violates the
dormant uh Commerce Clause
and
I would call this a violation of the
dormant
Commerce Clause that's my interpretation
that it looks like that is happening
what I would say is that in this case if
anything they would need to be an offset
which we're just not doing
now not everyone agrees with me on on
this I have shown some of the research
I've done to other members and I
understand it's a disagreement but
that aside the disagreement aside I
still look at it as a bad policy it
would completely disincent uh
anyone from who's a shareholder in a
corporation from wanting to live in New
Hampshire if they primarily working in
another state having to pay that State's
income tax and New Hampshire's dividends
tax
it just to me that's an extra high cost
that you can be paying in taxes
so I I look at I really look at that as
a bad policy
where
if you don't agree with them on the
legality of this I would still ask this
uh
support and passing this I've been asked
a lot of questions about how would this
impact the current uh lawsuit going on
that's before The Supreme Court I don't
believe this would have any any
influence on that because that's
involving a person working in solely in
New Hampshire
it's not and then they're being taxed
income tax in Massachusetts so it's
actually somewhat the opposite this is
in this scenario the person the
individual is still working and
operating in in Massachusetts and
they're still going that way they're
going there for work and they're still
being subject to the double taxation I
think it's very different when we're
talking about an individual income tax
not the dividends not the shareholder
just the actual employee so I don't
believe the two uh would have any impact
on each other
so I'm looking at this as something that
would encourage people who are living
here to stay here but also even more
people to move here and I think it would
really
result in an economic boost especially
along the bordering towns all through
New Hampshire not just the southern
border I think it would support the
borders on both uh by Vermont and Maine
as well and I can answer any questions
foreign
I
think what you're you're talking about
is uh distributions
that are given uh I was an owner of a
company or co-owner of a company in
Massachusetts
and then uh when we incorporate it as an
S corp we didn't realize that
distributions that I got to pay
my income taxes my federal taxes
was treated I also had to pay state
taxes on it on Massachusetts
uh but that distribution was counted as
Inc uh uh a dividend kind of uh
income in New Hampshire so I I for 38
years I've I had to pay the double tax I
agree that this is a quirk and we had a
bill about
um maybe eight years ago seven years ago
very much like this uh where we we
discussed this and I was I was very
happy thinking that this would get me
out from underneath it
uh but what happened then was that the
uh we did the math on it and there were
a lot more winners than losers or losers
or winners depending on which
perspective you had in terms of state
revenue so but I just want to clarify
that's what you're talking about the
correct distribution
and I think the dra will uh add a little
clarity as well when they testify but
you're talking about distributions I
mean I mean that's exactly what I'm
talking about the distributions from
being paid a dividend and I'm sorry that
you had to do that for 38 years because
I I look at that the case that I'm
referenced from the Supreme Court that
clarified this
came out in 2015 and the the caution
with that and I understand they can be
winners and losers but the caution is is
that Maryland lost and what happened to
Maryland is and I believe another state
was caused they had to refund a lot of
tax revenue to to taxpayers so there is
a a concern that if someone were to
challenge this and be successful and I
know if it was me and I just to give
full disclosure I don't have any share I
don't own any shares in any S
corporation I'm just if someone did
challenges they can be a large bill that
the state would have to pay
uh this doesn't necessarily remove that
liability but it also it is I've been a
Talk Amongst a lot of CPAs throughout uh
both States and I've I've had it I've
had even the conversation my own CPA
about it just you know what does he
think and it can be a big problem this
actually came to a head so this is also
a proactive situation just kind of put
put an end to this so it's not a problem
going forward
okay thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
representative Abbas for bringing this
to us today
um I I'm going to give a little analogy
and then ask you I'm just trying to
clear up my head on this
um I worked in the payroll uh for many
many years and uh inside those
computations we would always get into
arguments on whether or not you were
going to be taxed where you live or
where you worked and I had many
different uh conversations with those
above me and the different companies
that I work for about
is this is this sort of applying the
same here of what I'm understanding is
that you live in New Hampshire you're
being taxed in New Hampshire and you're
being taxed in Massachusetts is this a
live work or live operate uh uh
suggestion here
it's it's that thank you for the
question it's actually more of a hybrid
so
the difference between just individual
income tax if you let's say you're
working in New Hampshire remotely but
it's through a Massachusetts company
that scenario is where the individual is
working the dividend the distribution
payout has to do with the company of the
S Corps
profit margin and then they're
distributing some of those profits
making a distribution to its
shareholders at a certain time those
profits are then those are actually
still realized in the other state and
that's that's the company the ownership
of the company's different than the
individual income is that the company
operation is still out of state
so in that case it to me with this
scenario it's the reverse you're being
taxed because of where you live but
you're also being taxed because where
the S Corp is performing you're actually
getting both
so my whole the whole point of this is
that you're getting hit twice where you
should only be getting hit once whether
whether we agree that that should be
paid to New Hampshire or that should be
paid to Massachusetts that's a different
discussion but you should not be paying
both normally what happens is that the
states will have a reciprocal agreement
but because the states are calling it
different they're classifying it
differently I'm calling it apple and
orange
there's not there's no offset
so that's the problem there should be a
credit and it should go both ways if it
was the reverse situation and you're a
Incorporated in New Hampshire but you
slowly live in Massachusetts they're
actually doing the same thing and
they're violating it just as bad as the
state of New Hampshire
I would say
that's something that when you come to
those agreements on the on the offset
that's usually that's a that's a
different conversation to have with the
states because sometimes it is
disproportionate but
that I I would say it's kind of in
between the two because you're really
getting hit twice so regardless of where
you live and where your company is it's
both so
that's the way I was looking at it
represents
um thank you Mr chairman
um thank you representative Abbas I
think your explanation makes a great
deal of sense but I just want to make
sure I understand correctly we're not
talking about dividends or distributions
from companies who may own shares in
that are located in other states I think
we're talking only about pass-through
entities where the business tax goes on
the personal return uh in other words
Partnerships sub chapter S uh and llc's
am I correct in making that distinction
so when I answer you when we answer this
and just say that I am not a tax expert
I I don't practice tax law I'm not a
certified CPA so when I look at I'm
talking mostly with dividends paid
through an S corporation
and when I look at that that's what's
getting to me I'm is being taxed twice
the business profits tax my
understanding is is not
oh it's not the same situation that if
I'm wrong about that then it it would
still be I still would think that's
violating that the Commerce Clause too
but I'm looking at this is where the
person's working in Massachusetts
they're not contesting that they should
be taxing to Massachusetts they're just
everything's done there they just simply
reside here and by living here you're
being taxed a dividends tax that's
already been taxed in Massachusetts
whether it's but it's whether it's an
LLC or a partnership it would be the
same principle being violated it just
it's just another analogy to be made but
I think there I would put all those in
the same category but this is where it's
happening the most
so so just to clarify the way I'm
understanding your answer
I don't believe this is applies to a
situation where a C corporation exists
in another state and Massachusetts does
not purport to apply attacks on a
dividend sent to a resident of New
Hampshire it applies in the case of tax
uh pass-through entities where the
individual receiving the dividend or
distribution is actually the person
receiving the profit on the
Massachusetts company
correct that that is that is correct
representative
on president of Abbas on
it's I'm wondering
on if you're you're asking us to
unilaterally on
remove ourselves from taxing anything
that Massachusetts is taxing it sounds
like to me because we can't get
Massachusetts to do agreements with us
as far as I can tell on do you realize
that if we have lower taxes at the state
level here your property tax is going up
thank you
well just to thank you for the question
first of all I think that's an
assumption that the property taxes go up
and to make a grand over broad statement
about how the local governments will
change their tax rates and I I think
that's that's over that's too broad of a
statement to make
and I what I'm referring to here is
this is something the Supreme Court has
decided whether I like it or not is not
it's that's I can have my own personal
opinion on it but I just look at the
this is something that they've ruled on
several times saying a double taxation
is inappropriate and just just like any
other presidents I'm looking at it and I
see it happening and I'll be honest if I
was the plaintiff or if I was hit with
this I would challenge it and I would
say well I'm not sure that you're
allowed to do this so that would cost
the state a lot of money having to
refund all that money and when it comes
to property taxes if if there was
there's already a lot of great
incentives to live in New Hampshire and
it's I it's one of the I would say the
best state to live in the entire country
but there are people that would make the
financial decision to not live here for
that reason simply to avoid this double
taxation
I would believe that this would create a
more of an incentive to move here which
would perhaps develop more areas which
would create more revenue and property
taxes just by developing more homes but
it would also improve the economic
activity in the area where you have
people who perceivably have disposal
income to spend to support local
businesses there will be a lot of domino
effects of actually having uh getting
rid of this it's just not it's not
simply black and white like this so I
don't actually agree that real estate
taxes would go up especially along the
bordering parts of the state but I also
believe that it is still a policy that's
really it's negatively impacting a lot
of people
sure
any further questions Mr chair
representative
thank you Mr a question for you
will we see a fiscal note come on this
from someone
we have two other people signed up to
testify one from the pi all right
thank you
for the questions
from this uh
I will go to Eric Blackburn and thank
you members of the committee
oh okay I'm sorry
and
we're going down here
on the era
Carol good morning Mr chair members of
the committee my name is Carolyn Lear
and I'm the assistant commissioner at
the New Hampshire Department of Revenue
um and I think representative of Abbas
did a really nice job of really framing
this issue for you all
um I took his testimony to really frame
this as a two-part issue for you to
consider one would you consider whether
to amend the interest in dividends tax
statute because of constitutionality
concerns and the other is for you to
amend the statute based on um sort of a
policy uh policy-based cost benefit
analysis is this good for New Hampshire
um and I would like to address both of
those sort of issues in turn
so relative to the constitutionality of
how um New Hampshire
taxes um the pass-through income of
Resident S corporation shareholders I
think
all I would caution you with is this
idea of conceding the
unconstitutionality of the statute
um I think if we were to
get this as a lawsuit we would say that
it is not unconstitutional
um the reason being that
um New Hampshire and Massachusetts
really has a functionally different
method of taxing both individuals and
businesses
um in Massachusetts as everyone
correctly heard if you're a corporation
you will pay income tax at the corporate
level
and then if the shareholders receive
income from that Corporation
um they will also pay income tax on
those distributions
somewhat different in Massachusetts is
that an S corporation doesn't pay tax at
the entity level those profits just get
sent right down to their shareholders
and as representative Abbas mentioned
our tax
if those shareholders
um are in New Hampshire we then look to
those shareholders for IND tax and
that's very similar to what we would do
to a shareholder of a C Corp or a
partner in a partnership
um so for that reason we would just
caution on just conceding that
constitutional issue I think we might
want to assert
um that the IND tax is just different
from what Massachusetts is doing and
perhaps consistent with our overall
scheme of how we tax interest
um of individuals and tax businesses at
the entity level
moving on to sort of the more
policy-based reason why you might want
to
um consider this bill as you might
expect we don't really take a position
on that I think that's for you folks to
really
um evaluate and decide I know there was
some interest earlier in the potential
impact of this legislation we were not
asked to do a fiscal note for this
legislation and I'm not sure that we
would have the data to come up with a
good
um fiscal note for this bill but um I
would suspect
um that it would have a fiscal impact
simply be because of the cross-border
nature of a lot of shareholders in New
Hampshire who live in New Hampshire but
own an interest in an entity that's in
Maine or Massachusetts or Vermont
um where there are income taxes
um so it could have a fiscal impact and
I think that's really not my prerogative
to sort of weigh in on whether
um the costs and benefits work out
otherwise I am happy to answer any
questions from the committee
representative Brahman
and it's later how are you good how are
you good
so as I mentioned earlier this issue
came up uh probably seven or eight years
ago
um and it came up even before then there
was a commission to look at all our
taxes
um maybe representative major and uh I
don't remember this
and it was identified that this was one
of our more quirky
kind of thing of the way we
tax businesses I remember that word
clearly was quirky uh and uh but at that
time when this became a bill there was a
bill that we dealt with we did get some
estimates of revenues
uh maybe it was a rough estimate
because that's what made the committee
shy away from doing anything about this
because
it was it was it appeared that there'd
be a lot of loss Revenue to the state at
a time where we couldn't afford that
lost Revenue now obviously
I was I would have been in a beneficiary
of this bill that you know this type of
Bill passing when I was still working
I'm retired now so uh but um so is there
any way possible that we can
get at least a rough estimate of somehow
fiscal of a fiscal amount on this
I could take that back to
um our financial analysts and see what
they could come up with
um perhaps we could
cross-reference if there's any
Massachusetts or federal data available
that might help us hone in on a rough
estimate right okay I appreciate
whatever you can do thank you sure
thank you
um
you accidentally muted yourself
okay
all right thank you
um yeah my question goes to the uh Point
made by representative abrami the
question or request for a fiscal note I
think we really need to have a fiscal
note I understand it may be difficult
all fiscal notes in fact have
difficulties uh and uh we get uh in the
course of dra doing a fiscal note we get
a good explanation of what the bill in
fact uh as they understand it would
would do and I think we really need that
in this case because there was uh
confusion I think amongst those who are
asking questions and uh and the answers
given
um and it left me wondering scratching
my head exactly what is the uh situation
that's of concern so I really hope that
we can get a uh fiscal note from dra
that explains their understanding of the
bill and then
um their identification if they can't do
a bottom line estimate of the factors
the cost factors
that go both ways that would weigh into
the impact so that's my uh it's really a
request to era
representative
uh yeah another question uh Slayer uh
could you help us out and and direct us
to exactly where in the statutes
uh we should be looking for can you find
a line in the in the statute current
statutes that
make these out of state distributions
taxable
in New Hampshire
so as not to
um
waste your time
perhaps I could follow up in an email
with identification of the exact
Provisions as I try to pull them up
that's what I was requesting okay sure
absolutely sorry I misunderstood oh no
no I don't want you I haven't scrambled
now to do that thank you perfect it'll
be helpful
thank you representative
thank you Mr chairman on Carolyn can we
is there some way that we could get
um a
history for the last 10 years or more of
of uh the number of high income uh pairs
of the IND that have uh disappeared I
know some of them will have disappeared
simply because they died
but we've had both I think this Bill and
for it
talk about high-end High income people
leaving the state because of this tax
and my remembrance of what the state
demographer has been telling us the last
couple of times is that we have more
low-income people leaving and high
income people coming in
thank you sure I can take a look at that
any further questions
anybody else wish to testify for against
this bill
huh say I'm not then I pause the public
hearing on House Bill 553
Mr chairman yes
could I just ask there was another bill
that on we were trying to get a fiscal
note on
and I'm trying to remember which number
it is now
um but that on they told us that we'd
have to do a vote in committee
in order to ask for one
oh it was the uh 346.
funding source for domestic violence
programs
that's not for today
no it's not until the 17th but it takes
a while to get those fiscal notes
sometimes
[Music]
on if I remember correctly you told me
that they said we had to do a vote in
Committee in order to ask for one and I
remember that from previous rules too
we've never done it
but we've never had this many bills
without fiscal notes that should have
had them HB 102 also should have a
fiscal note but on
I don't think that the sponsor expects
it to to go ahead as an actual bill but
as a retained study
I will ask again
[Music]
any other questions
I just have a comment I'm having a hard
time hearing you representative major
is this better
yes thank you yes it comes off and on
take it off
any
further questions from Community Control
[Music]
thank you
are we through for the morning
to one o'clock
we're through to one yes that's right
okay thank you thank you represent
Griffin
Elliott if you like you can um look at
the bottom left of your screen and you
can press mute and you can press stop
video if you want to just
um set it and just be able to come back
later
stop video now your box is just black
with your name on it and then if you
press mute then nobody will hear any
background noise
perfect
thank you
foreign
hi representative major representative
verstein representative abrami anybody
else in the room
um just a reminder if someone would go
up to the computer station and press
unmute before you're ready to begin
go to where
Jen no uh just for people in the
committee room
oh okay gotcha
I didn't think so
representative Tucker how's your
testimony go
you're muted
I had written I had some written
testimony so I just synopsized that I
don't think I was brilliant
testing testing Can you folks hear me
misrepresentative Rami okay uh Jennifer
can you tell me can you tell us if uh
Sean Packard's uh out there somewhere on
um I do not see him in the attendee list
no at all huh
you're supposed to be introducing the
Bell
[Music]
my dog had taken care of the text thing
do you want me to feed him
like you're live by the way
mites are alive yes
there's a mic right here
[Laughter]
okay everybody uh we're gonna we're
gonna start the afternoon session uh
you're probably wondering why I'm
sitting in the chair seat uh uh for new
members Norma major is a sponsor of this
bill
the coast Parts on the co-sponsored the
Bell uh therefore he can't speak on the
bill
uh so I'm going to be chairing this one
and the next one as well
so uh
our understanding is that Sharon Packard
is the prime sponsor on this bill
uh and that he he was uh supposed to be
testifying he's still not there uh
Jennifer or Jenny
no
all right what we're going to do is have
uh you ready we're gonna have
representative major uh introduce to
Bill
which one over here too
oh there's one there too yeah
there you go
can you hear me
can you hear me okay
not very well
can he sit at the table
can you guys hear uh the chairman
not very well
okay do you want to move it up That's
Mike
yeah why don't we why don't we move it
back up there normally like like I did
all right we're just gonna do a little
uh rearranging here
a little closer a Little Closer
okay
how's this can you hear me
cry again can you hear me okay
not I don't know what does everybody
think
sort of struggle to hear him at all he
didn't say and get closer to your
microphone and representative hack and
Phillips can't hear you
is that better
yes
right yeah that was a good news
uh
the bill
bill
ing ten
so this is uh uh House Bill 10 uh that
that's going to be introduced by uh
representative major
uh right now
okay I'm going to enter this house bill
10 and act relative to the rights of the
business practice tax and business
Enterprise tax crime sponsor was
representative Insurance packet
that we're here right at this moment
but essentially what this bill does
the Grimes we talked with
office tax rate from 7.7 which is now
in two years
now
[Music]
it brings the business Enterprise tax
rate of
0.60 now
two
zero point five percent two years from
now
this is the plan scheduled
[Music]
the rate induction business
processed years ago
is here so
um
yeah well we're right we're out on time
here uh Mr Speaker
[Music]
okay
okay so representative uh Packard's uh
gonna pick up mid-sentence here
yes can I say welcome Mr speaker thank
you it's good to see you thank you thank
you so much
I'm not sure how far north Scott but um
this is I think most of you realize this
was
one of our uh former speakers
uh bills I mean when he passed away I
took over
it uh
I'm sure all of you have read it pretty
simple
it reduces the business profit stacks
and the business Enterprise tax
until we get down to 7.5 percent for the
business profit
and point five percent for the
business
that's what it says okay thank you
you're probably only either going to
agree with it or disagree with it but
that's that's the whole context
[Music]
you want to take questions
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Packard for making the
presentation
at least a simple bill here I I do have
a question
uh do you have any uh data that shows of
a tax rate reduction in the BPT or the
BET as proposed by this bill would have
a positive impact
on state revenues
well I mean being from purple you honest
we're not 100 sure we'll have a positive
impact but we do know that when you
reduce taxes it has a positive impact on
business and uh business Enterprise and
the money that extra the business extra
money that they have to spend so we
believe it's an absolute positive move
forward that will bring more business
into the state it will help businesses
in the state stay in business and uh
help them expand once we get out of this
pandem thank you representative uh any
other questions I I don't have a
computer in front of me so can someone
uh Jen can you Jenny can you
okay representative please
thank you on Mr Speaker I just wanted at
this point to bring up a procedural on a
problem in our rsas which has been there
since you started cutting the business
taxes on that I just realized on in both
the business profits tax and the big
we just lost our audio you muted
yourself accidentally
thank you
myself I don't know what mute you again
um I do apologize on I don't know when
where I started but on I want to read
from
uh section
77a20a distribution of funds for the
business profits tax and the business
Enterprise tax uh is approximately the
same thing the commissioner shall
determine the additional amounts of
Revenue produced by an increase of 1.5
percent in the rate of tax imposed by
77.82 for each fiscal year and she'll
certify such amounts to the state
treasurer by October 1 of that year for
deposit in the education trust fund
established by RSA
198.39 on now
I've consulted Phil sletton of the New
Hampshire fiscal policy Institute he
says that people have been finessing
this
for quite a while but essentially what
they're saying is that if each time you
lower the tax less money should be going
into the education trust fund so my
question is
is this going to be amended and if so in
which way are we going to continue to
ignore the law and just send what we
originally promised to the education uh
trust fund on or are we going to remove
it from the general fund who's going to
lose on this
thank you well it's an assumption uh
representative that we're going to lose
on this we don't believe you are going
to lose in the long run so I guess I
would just have to disagree with your
assessment
any other uh oh any other well I guess
we do have two more questions uh uh
Edith uh Tucker police Senator
representative Tucker
yes uh did you consider lowering the
business Enterprise tax War
and why did you reject that as an as a
as an outcome
I'm I'm not sure I mean to reduce it
below 0.5 percent
yeah
uh this well honestly representative
this is the bill that working Center had
written I just took over the final
Quantum so obviously I can't ask them
why you take point five percent I was
around when the business Enterprise tax
was first put in place
and
at that point it was 0.25 and it's
placed it went up as high as 0.275 and
now we're bringing this we're suggesting
that you bring it back to uh
could I follow up please let's follow up
uh the reason I ask is that
my understanding is that the BET really
is the sort of the mom-and-pop branch of
New Hampshire this is the group that has
really
been pained and hurt by the pandemic
so I was wondering whether we shouldn't
be considering even a lower amount for
the vet
representative anytime you want to lower
taxes on primary
I'm sorry I couldn't understand you
representative anytime you want to lower
taxes you won't get an argument from me
I'm absolutely fine with it will lower
it more that's fine with me great thank
you very much
uh Mr got two more questions still
wanted a quick question uh Tim Horrigan
please tell them in representative
Horgan
representative abrami I'm sorry
representative Horrigan signed up to
testify on the bill oh he did okay he's
trying to indicate yeah
uh just a question from uh Drew Klein or
Drew Klein's done a member so he can't
ask questions
so uh I guess we're all set then uh
thank you very much Mr Speaker
next up is going to be representative
major
who uh emergency
Have you shared uh for us in the room he
uh handed out two charts president
handed out two charts uh I don't know
does does everybody else have access
online have access to these two charts
oh
put your share the screen
again I don't have a computer in front
of me
uh
no I guess we don't I guess we don't
have it but Norm uh representative major
will talk us through the charts
and then uh make sure that everybody
gets these these charts uh
afterwards
representative major
thank you Mr chairman
yeah the two charts
to better understand
what's happening to the DCT
we've changed the rate and what and what
happens to the revenues that question
was already asked
what I did is I made a copy of the chart
from one of the handouts that was given
to us in our orientation
and on page 17
a it's the bptvt revenue 10-year trend
and I looked at that and that 10-year
Trend was from 2011.
to 2020.
what's striking
if you take
from 2011
to
2015 that was before
there's a break changes in the p-e-t OR
BPT
that the changes in the total revenue
business Revenue
490.2 million dollars
to 560 61 million dollars
or 71.5 million dollar increase
from 2011 to 2015
14.6 increase
and that was the vpt rate of eight and a
half percent which I've been there for a
while and the BBT rate of 0.75
the next four years
from 2015
the 2019 we started reducing the rates
of the business profits on the business
Enterprise tax
where we went from
a rate of eight and a half percent in
2015 to 7.7 percent in 2019 over four
weight loss from 825 to 8.2
7.97.7 percent
which is a total drop of
0.8 percent
in the same time we dropped the rate of
the bet
from 0.75
to 0.6 percent
over that same time period over four
different weight loss
and what happened to the revenues
well the revenues fly Under the Red Rock
over those four years
had risen 14.6 percent
over the next four years and dropping
the rights of the BPT and the bet
the rivers grew
243.9 million dollars or a total of
43.7 percent in this in four years the
previous boy is that without any rate
drops the revenue increase 14.6 let me
say that again
in these four years when you saw the
rape drops
the revenues increased by
243.9 million dollars
so that question of what happened when
you make rate drops and to the revenues
in this case what it did it encouraged
more economic activity which you can
tell it's greater revenues
thank you
questions questions press the button
any other questions of Representative
major
oh
representative Army
unmute
sorry I suggest that we first compare
these growth rates with uh the national
GDP and the stock market rates which
seem to have quite a lot to do with our
our tax growth on and also would remind
you I think it was 2016 the first year
there that you're talking about that we
finally recovered from the Great
Recession and started to grow again
thank you
okay thank you uh is there a question
the question was uh shouldn't we compare
it with the source of our Revenue which
is mostly outside this outside the state
representative major you want to respond
to it
what I did in this announcement that the
total revenue growth the revenue is made
up of corporate taxes yes a lot of the
corporate taxes
comes from corporations outside the
state and the profits that they make in
that state
and uh
the reason that they put profits within
our state because
we don't tax corporations
as far as the DVP
if you look
the very recession is
0708 and 9 it took a while to run out
started this analysis into the positive
in 2011
the world was stagnant
I mean it went up
from 2011 490 million dollars
516 million in 2012
551 in 2013.
in 549 2014.
in 2015 was 561. it was
the growth is it was almost why
no
in 2016
we had our first record
and it was a 699
and then
through 2019
805. seconds
so it was
quite a steep whoa
in those four years while we were
reducing rates
okay
um
yeah
can you hear me
yes okay
um I guess my question is uh along the
same lines as the question that was just
asked and I think
we all know that there are many
variables that affect uh the prophets
reported by our time the taxable
businesses in New Hampshire
um and those variables obviously uh then
um
well the variables in the tax collected
is dependent on
the
factors that representative Ami spoke to
um and to the uh and I'm not saying this
very well there there's tax rates and
there's the profit amount and the amount
of profit that's reported each year is a
function of many things and one is the
larger National economy another is the
international economy and another is the
state economy and
than the amount collected depends on the
rates and I my question to you
representative major is wouldn't you
agree that in making any judgment
as to how
what the impact of a rate change at the
state level
has been would be
that's a very careful assessment of
those other factors including changes in
the federal tax law for example
is needed and that when you go through
such an examination it's uh it's not
easy to do other kind of conclusions
that you suggested we should draw
from
from the data you were looking at
[Music]
I'm having a hard time hearing you I'm
sorry
I gotta talk into the microphone
representative
yeah right the amount of vectors
involved in determining uh
represent major yes you may want to take
your face mask down with the help
question
he's very socially distanced for those
not in the room
right there's at least six feet apart
between us
yeah you're right there's a lot of
vectors involved in determining what the
economic effects today on total revenue
GDP
unemployment right now is the pandemic
rate changes a lot of variables but
overall
what I did is I looked at the two
periods generally professional first
period of four years you had all kinds
of things going on the same as you have
outlines of things going on
but the sum of everything
is that while these great changes were
going on
there wasn't a year that wasn't any
better
that was worse than the previous four
years it changes
so I will compose on that
that
this does show where rate changes
and they're very small incremental
rating
could not
was not detrimental to the total income
but there is you know if you lower the
rate
you may just get
more businesses to come in here more
businesses that generate more revenues
you said
I think I am for now I I look forward to
continuing dialogue and discussion with
representative major and others as we go
into work sessions to look at the facts
facts are facts and uh we uh can try to
come to a common understanding of what
has happened to help us forecast what
will happen I think this is very murky
territory I'm sure representative major
would agree it's incredibly complex as
he says there are many different vectors
come into play and uh let's all look at
it together and do an honest assessment
uh if
yeah I'll leave it at that and I
certainly would love
I'll be glad we can sit down
[Music]
yes I I agree we are definitely have
work session on this bill so uh so
there's two more uh members no uh okay
representative uh Schomburg waves off uh
representative ulery we have a question
of uh representative major
there it is yes
um
if I recall correctly in the past
with the exception of the tobacco tax
when there's been a modification
downward
of our taxes
there's been an increase in Revenue
all right yes Susan I see you smile
that's the nice thing about this
distance stuff at any rate
I remember getting
um some facts as representative Ames uh
spoke about
from LBA regarding what has happened in
uh over time whenever we've done this uh
that may be helpful don't you agree
representative major
yes
you know there are certain things that
aren't as complex such as the bear tax
if we rate if we lower the rate on that
we would definitely reduce our revenues
because the same set over the years the
volume of the there that is taxed has
been very consistent
so definitely if you are right there
hey uh any other questions of
Representative major I see none thank
you very much
so look we have uh two other uh well we
have uh one other uh individual who
would stand up in a pink card if you
will and then we have Department of
Revenue and then we have two other hands
that are up so I'm going to start with
Department of Revenue and then uh Greg
Moore your next Tim representative
Horrigan your next after that and then
Jewel Klein your next after that so
let's start with Department Revenue
that's uh uh do you want to be honest
Melissa Rollins and uh Carolyn Lair do
you want to do this together
oh can we can we open about both
together
great thank you representative abrami
thanks for promoting both Carol and Lear
the assistant commissioner of the
Department of Revenue as well as myself
Melissa Rollins senior financial analyst
with the Department of Revenue I just
want to make sure you can hear me first
yes Ken okay perfect
all right so I um you've seem pretty
familiar with the bill so far it's been
explained very well that the business
rates go down twice in this bill so I'm
just going to speak to our fiscal note
and our fiscal analysis
we have provided a fiscal note quick
guide which basically mirrors the fiscal
note that you have in front of you
that's back to the bill so if you want
to look at that while I'm chatting it
might make a little bit more sense as I
go through
first off I want to note this is a
static analysis our fiscal impact is
indeterminable
during the static analysis our starting
point was fiscal year 2020 Cash basis
plus anomalous Revenue you've heard us
in the past couple of weeks talk a lot
about this anomalous Revenue you know
that it belongs back in fiscal year 20.
so our starting point for business taxes
as a whole is the 69 or
697.5 million
so we take that amount and then we need
to tweak it a little bit to get it to be
the true amount for fiscal year 20 which
is bringing it to 691.5 million and
that's because you've heard me speak
before about how tax years cross
multiple fiscal fiscal years
and in fiscal year 20 we are feeling the
last impact of excuse me in fiscally or
21 we're feeling the last impact of our
last rate reduction so we need to adjust
for that prior to this bill being put
forth so our starting point is 691.5
million we then take that amount
and we apply the applicable rates based
on each fiscal year to get our to get us
to our bases and once we have the bases
we then are applying the rates as we
move forward and the reason we have the
chart that's in the sheet it's called
proposed legislation rates in splits
it's a good visual to show you how the
tax years cross each fiscal year because
there's a lot of moving parts from
making this calculation
so using those rates and splits and
applying the base to each of those race
rates and splits
we end up with a final estimated
cumulative fiscal impact
starting in fiscal year one fiscal year
21 of negative 5.9 million with a total
cumulative fiscal impact of 53.7 million
in fiscal year 24 which is the time
we'll feel the full impact of all of
those rate changes
happy to answer any questions
any questions from anyone
any hands up
okay thank you I'm sure we'll be talking
to you both more about this as we
proceed forward on this oops I think
representative Almy has a question I
can't see hands warm okay sorry I need
uh Jenny I need your help on that so so
remember I mean yep
thank you Melissa thank you Mr chairman
I'm assuming we're starting with fiscal
year 20 which
is
probably going to be our lowest but it
may be our second lowest Suite it won't
know until April on on Revenue
on to the state from these taxes and
so it really is how much we actually
lose from this is going to depend on how
much revenue we get from uh the re
rebound from the
on recession though that in the past has
always been slower in New Hampshire than
elsewhere uh what I was
asking for other than why we started in
20.
um is you're using for this whole thing
the division of bet from BPT according
to the 37 percent that it was in 20 on
but we know that we hope that a lot of
that is going to change again towards
the 40 percent that you always use as
the general number
um once
we are all are vaccinated for coven
which in my case is going to be a long
time
and uh could go back to restaurants and
the restaurants could start opening
again
given that they've turned a lot
hopefully they're going to come back
almost to what they were before so on
the BET should be growing back relative
to BPT and I'm not sure what that does
to your conclusions
yeah but that's a great Point
representative elmy we do always try to
put in a little note to say if the
starting point of our revenue is
adjusted then our Revenue impact will be
off it's very hard we did we did do this
um these fiscal impacts at the end of
fiscal year excuse me at the end of
December beginning of November so we
weren't exactly sure where fiscal year
21 was going to end and because of covid
it made it really hard to say let's use
fiscal year 21 plan because we weren't
we weren't sure at that time if we were
even going to meet plan or not so our
safest gas at that point was to use
fiscal year 20. so obviously if the
revenues increase or if that split does
change between the BET and BP team there
will be some impacts however I'm not
sure if it will be a drastically impact
just because of the Back Credit against
the BPT might offset that a little bit
all right I was wondering if we could
possibly get just one sensitivity
analysis on that
for this this group and we've we've
never really looked at the impact of of
the bet
uh BPT split
it's wrong with you you want to respond
to that
sure we can we can look into that and
see if we can come up with
um see if we can come up with a
sensitivity analysis to see how much it
does impact it or not we can absolutely
take a look at that so so for all the
members you know we're going to get into
the weeds with Barbara view on this one
so uh you know these people when we do
our work sessions I'm sure we're gonna
we're gonna dig into this so
so any other questions for uh Melissa
Rollins
no okay thank you Melissa thank you
um I want to apologize to representative
Harrigan uh protocol is that
Representatives go before others so I'm
going to call on representative Oregon
if you're still there well I'm still
there
I just start speaking now or do you want
to add me to the panel I'm happy either
way you're not missing much by not being
able to see me the representative we
can't hear you okay thank you very much
Mr chair
um
so I guess so you well this is I guess
right now I'm uh an attendee but I'm I'm
able to speak that's good enough you
won't be able to see me probably but
you're not missing much um so I'm in
opposition uh opposition to this bill I
think um I think it would do nothing but
reduce the amount of Revenue coming into
the state and um
both the speaker and representative
major made what are what many of you
recognize as Laffer Curve Arguments for
the tax cuts which is supposedly when
you cut taxes business activity will go
up so much you'll get the same revenue
or more that's
an unrealistic assumption I actually
studied economics with Dr Laffer and I
don't know whether he would have been
opposed or in favor of this bill he
actually probably would have been more
likely in favor but
um first of all the rates to which that
kicks in are much higher than um higher
than what the rate of our business taxes
and business profits have been an
Enterprise tax so the inflection point
on that curve where you start losing
money raise taxes is for most types of
taxes weigh up around 90 you know we're
talking about
0.55 percent of something the business
profits tax versus just on profits which
is just part of what business has taken
you know it's whatever seven seven point
seven percent now
um the business Enterprise tax which
it's kind of like an income tax
but it's paid by the employer not by the
employee and it's not every employer and
every employee so I guess that makes it
narrow enough not to be a broad-based
income tax but it works very much like
the income tax of everybody who works
for a covered um thing that's
0.6 percent and I think these are also
the Laffer Curve effect you know supply
side effect depiction only when the uh
when only only when there's a
significant change when there's also
there's structural because they can kick
in and also people have to be confident
it's going to stick around and none of
these apply to this you could probably
totally eliminate the business
Enterprise tax and you do nothing but
lose all that Revenue I think that would
probably have little or no effect on
businesses on this also growth in
business it um relies a lot more than
low taxes um you need you need a good
government for businesses to grow you
need businesses need a Workforce you
know they need a Judicial System they
need Transportation they need all kinds
of things that government pays for so
like at least some of what government
does it's very beneficial the business
community so and also
um the government also is a major
customer for private business so they're
one of the largest uh you know there are
many many businesses rely on the
government as a as a customer too and of
course also government spending we also
saw that it's not inherently bad for the
economy when we had essentially
1.25 billion dollars of free
virtually free Federal money was dumped
on us you know government spending
um government spend it all and um
economy improved as a result so it
perfect
we're really running behind uh yes my
last comment is um thank you last
comment is
um
these tax cuts are the way they are
because and it's been in there for
several budget Cycles I think dating
back to the 2015 budget and uh
so there was a possibility the tax rate
could go up if economy shrank and it
never shrank until uh the pandemic
happened so we had an unexpected
catastrophe so it actually
shrank released prior to the year so
that was the first time impact increase
through these the way these trigger this
law is written
it could even happen and um it was uh
you know effective the amount that it
goes up would have gone up is very
exaggerated I remember even back then we
had the budget briefing I asked Neil
Kirk
um this looks like
tax rate could actually go up under
certain circumstances my friends would
be really amazed at such that he would
consider such a thing and he assured me
and there's a reasonable answer that
that would be virtually impossible but
then last year many things that are
virtually impossible actually happened
and one of them was that uh
these triggers that these uh you know
the economy shrank enough to trigger a
possible tax increase so anyway I think
uh
you know you'll have plenty of work
sessions and I'm I know a lot less about
this than the uh the committee and
you'll have plenty of Works Essence a
wide variety of sessions but I think
I think this bill is a bad Bill I think
it will do nothing except uh just lower
the revenue and we'd either have to uh
thank you very much we had to get it
somewhere else so that's that's why I'm
opposed to it so thank you very much
Horrigan any questions for
representative Horgan I would first off
do willing to take questions sure yes
that's fine any any questions
no thank you thank you very much thanks
a lot thanks okay
um we have two more that will uh I'm
gonna testify uh just for those who are
waiting for the next meeting uh the next
meeting the next is uh house bill 15.
will probably be another 10 or 15
minutes on this on this bill so just
hang in there please
thank you uh
Greg Moore from the American American
Prosperity uh New England chapter
uh you can we uh let Greg Moore in
please
I'm here
okay great thank you thank you thank you
Mr chairman members of committee on I'm
I'm glad I'm more punctual for this uh
hearing than for the one this morning so
so I appreciate your patience with that
uh as you may know I'm Greg Moore I'm
the state director with Americans for
Prosperity here in New Hampshire and so
the veteran members of the committee you
know that we have long been proponents
for reducing the states to business
primary business taxes and uh we've been
involved since this began even before
2015 and and we believe that this is as
a hugely beneficial opportunity for this
day to grow our economy uh
representative major did a great job of
outlining how even with lower rates the
state was seeing record business tax
revenues and I think it's important to
look Beyond just the impact on revenues
I know that's this committee's purview
but to look beyond the impact of Revenue
and look at the other economic factors
and and the impact that's having on the
lives of people across the state we saw
a tremendous job growth wage growth we
had a Workforce participation number
that was uh in the top five nationally
prior to the pandemic and and that's
great we had
um 72 percent pushing 73 of of uh the
people in the work people in the
workforce age were actually engaged in
work which is which is absolutely
fantastic and I would submit to you that
the the the track of the growth in our
Workforce participation number uh
aligned pretty closely with with the
business tax reductions we started in 20
in the 2015 budget that actually began
January 1st of 2016. and these benefits
come as a result of just becoming more
competitive through the three rounds of
tax relief we have now lowered our
corporate profits tax below that of
Massachusetts and we're now better
positioned regionally with our business
tax environment to compete for those for
those employers to come to New Hampshire
or to have existing employers grow here
and I think that's an important factor
to keep in mind that making sure that we
have good jobs particularly as we come
out of a pandemic this is going to be
critical over the long term House Bill
10 would continue to expand that
Advantage with a particular focus on
small businesses because of the nature
of the the focus of this one the first
two rounds the ones that were included
in the 2015 budget really were
emphasizing the business profits tax uh
the the two rounds that were included in
the 2017 budget which of which this bill
would actually finally Implement that
fourth round over two years we'll really
focus more on the business Enterprise
tax which as this committee knows truly
benefits to small businesses that have
been ravaged so dramatically uh and
through as a result of the pandemic uh
there's one other thing I want to point
out I know that one of the things we
talk about is revenue but it's important
as we're talking about Revenue to sort
of look at some of the changes in the
last legislature looking at the Surplus
statement that was attached with with
the last budget house bills three and
four from 2019 one of the things we note
is just by going through that Surplus
statement tax law changes as a result of
Senate Bill 190 and House Bill 4
resulted in at least estimated but at
the time 41 41 and a quarter million
dollars in tax increases on businesses
and that's that's a result of changing
things on reinforcement reinforcement
and Conformity as well as taxing of
global investment low tax income or GI
LTI uh now I'll say the the policy
changes the policy changes that took
place through reapportionment the policy
changes that took place as a result of
Conformity they stand up on their own
those policy changes make sense made
sense on their own however as you
broaden that base it's also important to
to reduce rates and the way I view it
that the changes that are included in
House Bill 10
do
follow up to the tax law changes in in
the last legislature to basically get
business back to even and that and again
we are fully supportive of the idea of
Broad and base and lower rates so with
that in mind uh we stand fully
supportive of House Bill 10 and I'd be
happy to take any questions from the
committee
next question
um
thank you Mr Vice chair uh and
representative Nunez I'm sorry thank you
Mr
chair thank you Mr Moore for testifying
to us today it's good to see you on a
screen even though it's just your
picture
um uh when we talk about economic
downturns I think that we all need could
this be louder please
you want me to take down my mask is that
better
it's better I couldn't hear before thank
you so much and thank you for letting me
know that because I certainly want to be
heard uh Mr Moore when we talk about
economic economic downturns
um I think sometimes that we forget that
there are different there are different
levels of economic downturns some of
that is is a lack of consumer confidence
sometimes it is bad Planning by the feds
and sometimes it's about bad policy
introduction to the state level I think
that when we compare 2020
to other years a pandemic hit in 2020
and I don't think it's fair for us to
judge in 2020 but for us to look back in
the past and look at the growth that
we've had from reduction in business
taxes uh Mr Moore can you touch a little
bit more on the growth that we had over
the past several years before the
pandemic and looking at our unemployment
rate and where we're going right now and
the possibility for businesses to be
coming open again as they are in
Massachusetts and other areas that are
opening up their businesses right now I
think that we'll be following soon
hopefully
um can you talk to the level of
confidence that we'll have in our
economy here in the state and why
reducing this tax would help us
well at first I'd say uh I I tend to
look back at this as as a five-year
discussion not necessarily a one-year
discussion
um it's clear that without question what
happened what happened last year
I think we can all say that none of us
hopes that would ever happen again or
any time again in a near near term uh
but there's no question that as we
become more competitive that that gives
us an opportunity to go go and make the
case to businesses in other states and
the folks the folks over at Bea I think
do an outstanding job of recruiting
these businesses to come here so it's a
two-fold part it's it's the the lower
taxes particularly in the business
Enterprise tax side help our existing
small businesses here get back on their
feet particularly talking food service
and hospitality industry but uh
particularly the lowering of the
business profits tax is also important
even though even though this this
particular bill is focused more in the
business Enterprise because it allows us
to make the case businesses outside of
New Hampshire places like Massachusetts
places places like all across New
England and say this is the place to be
this is a place that wants to do
business with you and is going to be a
partner with you and we're sending a
clear Direction by saying that we are
going to continue a pro-growth economic
policy that that we're going to be on
your side and that's I think right now
and I think particularly coming out of
this pandemic what I think a lot of
employers want to hear that's that's
exactly the message we want to be
sending so so I think it's critical and
it's critical for us to keep sending
these positive positive messages to uh
to the community business Community to
say we we're going to be with you we're
going to we understand that it's you're
going through some tough times and even
even if some businesses who haven't
never been negatively impacted we want
to say we're the place that one wants to
work with you and wants to have you come
and be here and be part of our economy
so I think that that the message is this
sense directionally is also critical as
well
one more question for you uh
uh excuse me representative Rory
uh thank you Mr chair uh Mr Moore uh the
same question I asked earlier about a
historical analysis uh you and I have
both attended conferences with um Dr
Laffer who
is funny or Economist is funny but
um
excuse me but at any rate Tom do you
have any information from AFP regarding
the uh practical effect of reducing
um uh uh taxes and their and increasing
generation of revenue from uh any other
sources that we could uh uh use a study
for uh what representative Ames um uh is
seeking uh facts thank you
uh I I have done a bit of a literature
review on this uh certainly certainly
there there is plenty of uh confirmatory
evidence if that's the case of of
increased business activity but I think
it also depends uh as representative
major pointed out in his testimony that
uh that that sometimes consumption is
fairly stable and
um and increases in reduction in some
taxes
we'll have little or no little no impact
on the actual level of consumption uh as
much as I hate to say it the we've seen
that quite a bit with the meals and
Rental tax where increasing the tax rate
has not resulted necessarily in a drop
in consumption uh whereas there are a
lot of other taxes where where the
economic impact is more sensitive and I
think that that
um certainly certainly there's a great
deal of body of research and to the
extent that I can be helpful to the
committee I'd be happy to to look up and
try to identify any of that research and
provide it to the committee as as you
you deem necessary
okay thank you very much
uh thank you uh Mr Moore appreciate your
testimony thank you okay next up is uh
Drew Klein can we uh open him up
hi there thank you
um if everybody can hear me I think you
missed it so can you uh let us know who
you're representing these days sure yeah
so um I'll turn it up my volume a little
bit here I'm Drew Klein I'm president of
the Josiah Bartlett Center for Public
Policy the free market think tank in New
Hampshire and my interest in this is
testimony today is just to actually
answer some of the questions that I've
heard uh brought up by members of the
committee
regarding the effect of business tax
rate reductions on state revenues in the
past few years so if you go back to 2015
when you had the state budget debate
over the tax rate reductions Governor
Hassan predicted that the business tax
rate tax rate reductions would create a
90 million dollar hole in the upcoming
two-year budget
but what actually happened
instead business tax revenues came in
132.8 million or 23.4 percent above plan
in fiscal year 2016.
72.7 million or 12.9 percent above plan
in fiscal year 2017. the next budget
business taxes came in
118.8 million or 17.9 percent above plan
and fiscal year 2018. and
151.6 million or 23.2 percent above plan
and FY 2019.
so you look back at those four years
since the business tax rate reductions
began in 2016
business tax revenues exceeded budget
projections by a combined
475.6 million dollars
so we're talking about almost half a
billion dollars in new Revenue
unanticipated
um above budget projections
in 2017
the office of legislative budget
assistant projected that the additional
business tax rate reductions passed in
would cause an 11 million dollar
reduction in business tax revenues in
fiscal year 2019.
instead business tax revenues came in
15.16 million above plan that year
I am not saying that the business tax
revenues it caused all of those
increases as representative Bellamy
points out there was economic growth
elsewhere in the country
but I would point out
that GDP growth in the United States in
those four years and I just did this
quick calculation looking at Federal
Reserve data
economic growth in the U.S GDP growth
was 9.3 percent from 2016 to 2019. in
New Hampshire GDP growth was 11.6
percent so it was more than two percent
greater than the U.S average since we've
been cutting these business tax rates
um
I think the obvious takeaway is that the
way when you have this physical note
done by the Legislative budget assistant
um
that is as they say static it is not
Dynamic and what that means is that they
do not take into account when they do
this calculation what the effects of the
business tax rate changes would be on
Behavior I simply look at numbers on a
spreadsheet and when you consider what
the changes to business Behavior are you
see
that it does in fact stimulate some
additional economic activity and we know
this not just from art laugher who has
been brought up several times here as
the Godfather of supply side economics
but since then there's been a tremendous
amount of research from all sorts of
economists on the effects of business
tax rate changes and so you will find
some outlier Studies by and large they
do show that there is a negative effect
on economic growth from high business
tax rates and a positive effect on
economic growth from lower business tax
rates in addition in since this bill
does focus a little bit more on the bet
I think it's worth pointing out that
that effect is particularly strong with
small businesses I would point to a 2018
study by their Federal Reserve
so just a couple years ago
they did a study looking at
entrepreneurship and state Taxation and
their conclusion was
um and I can I can quote from the study
we find a quote we find that new firm
employment is negatively and
disproportionately affected by corporate
tax rates end quote
so there is a great body of literature
showing that lowering business tax rates
corporate tax rates does have a bit of a
stimulative effect on the economy can
help GDP growth and can particularly
help small businesses and since almost
all businesses in New Hampshire the
large majority are small businesses I
think one of the takeaways you can have
from lowering these rates particularly
the bet is that it would have a positive
effect on small business growth
and that's all I have thank you Mr Klein
any questions Mr Klein
any hands up
okay seeing no hands up thank you very
much Mr Klein appreciate it thank you
for any other hands up uh anybody else
want to testify who wants to testify
okay saying none
okay thank you I'm going to read the
blue shoot now all of these folks signed
up are in support of the Bell
Senator Hennessey Jonathan Smith Senator
Carson representative Lang
uh representative Tony lackas
uh David Juve from business Bia
Lisa post
Eric uh representing himself uh Eric
ratham represent himself and Alvin C
represent himself
okay uh with that I'm going to close uh
the hearing on House Bill 10.
yeah I know okay
next bill is house
bill 15.
and uh
we have representative Packard has
stayed with us thank you very much
representative Packard thank you for our
speaker Packard I should say uh for
hanging in here with us I just want to
say for the committee this is the bill
relatively including under the meals and
rooms tax facilitators of Internet
transactions of motor vehicle rentals
and facilitators of Internet
transactions of room uh occupancies
I just want to point out to the
committee those new nine members this is
a bill that we've worked on very hard
last year uh and that uh for whatever
reason didn't make it through the Senate
uh but I think and we merged
representative uh had a he was a sponsor
of the uh last year was the sponsor of
the uh uh the not the room of meals but
the auto the motor vehicle rentals piece
of this we merged the two bills last
year into one but with that I'll turn it
over to speaker
thank you Mr chairman actually this is
the third session we've had this because
remember in the first session
it was the Wayfarer decision we were
waiting for right exactly and then we
went into the second session and last uh
last year because of the pandemic it got
thrown in for the mix and it was one of
those 30 or 40 bills the Senate put
together and um and that one didn't make
it that one didn't make it through right
so this is the third try
uh first of all I want to I uh some
people have said that this is a tax a
new tax or a tax increase uh I want to
make sure everyone understands it is not
I think it was about 15 years ago
uh the legislature voted to include uh
motor vehicle rentals into the rooms and
meal Stacks I can't remember exactly how
many years
since then we've had a new type of um
rental company come into existence
um they have people it's it's I think
it's based some way on the same thing as
Uber is where people use their personal
cars only this one the people rent their
personal cars
uh through different companies and one
of the bigger ones that we run into was
a company called churro out of
California
the other facilitator
of the rental
and let's say representative Doucette
has an extra cash he wants to rent it
well he can rent that car through Toro
and then he gets a percentage of the
money
so what we discovered and it was brought
to our attention by the rental car
companies is that
if we're going to charge the rental car
companies the nine percent
than anybody renting a car should be
charged to nine percent
pretty simple
that's why I I am I am insistent that
this is not a new tax this is something
that's fair
if you want to get rid of the nine
percent in the rental car companies go
for it I'm all for it but if you're
going to keep the nine percent on the
rental car companies then I think any
company renting a car should have to pay
the nine percent
that's pretty much what this uh what
this bill does uh I'll let you address
Mr chairman the other part on the Airbnb
part because obviously that was a thing
that you instituted you know into this
bill there were two bills and I
understand that
so
that's all this bill does is it makes it
a plain a fair playing field it's that
if one company is going to be charged
nine percent and this company is over
here it's a different model they do it
differently but it's still a rental car
company
so
all I'm asking is that um we will
forward with this bill and make it fair
for those rental car companies out there
okay we just discovered that I'm also a
sponsor on the bill so I I shouldn't be
chairing this so we're going to ask Alan
Bernstein to to uh this is for the
committee well actually Mr chairman you
can share as long as you don't get into
any discussion or ask any questions okay
thank you
as long as you don't testify and you
don't ask questions
all right you cannot or I could care
is a member uh is a member of the
committee whether president here who was
here last year or on I want to explain
the airbn but we used to call it the
Airbnb bill
uh to someone want to just add a little
light on that for for the rest of the
members representative Al May will
okay representative recognize
thank you on last year we we had been
dealing the dra had been dealing for
quite some time with this issue with
Hotel lodgings uh the hotel lodging
companies that arranged on the internet
for
um they would buy up large quantities of
hotel rooms in in New Hampshire for
instance and then offer them at lower
prices than what they would be be
offered at by the hotel itself and it
did that because it was not paying the
nine percent
it declared that the nine percent was a
commission that had nothing to do with
the regular cost
and the dra can probably correct me on
this if if they want to but on and the
DIA finally managed to reach an
agreement with Airbnb that they would
pay the nine percent but that left all
the smaller companies that were doing
this and it left Airbnb at a
disadvantage with those companies
so on
that it was brought there was a lawsuit
which the dra can tell you more about
there was a lawsuit on by some of those
companies saying we don't have to pay
this and it went to our Supreme Court
and our Supreme Court New Hampshire said
uh you're right under the law the way it
is now you can't you don't have to pay
this but if they just change this piece
yes yes you should be paying this
and so that's why that bill came in it
was sponsored by representative Butler
who uh did not run again this term who
runs a small BNB which was being
discriminated against by this also on
and
on
that bill also it was something that we
were going to put through very easily
there was no opposition to it on
developing it all and uh we got hit by
the uh
the sentence on the bus
requirements and we put those together
largely because they're they are doing
exactly the same thing from two
different segments of Industry on to
exactly the same sections of the statute
and we wanted to make sure that it was
consistent
so that's why that piece of this is in
here and
um it seems to it there may be a company
or two still trying to avoid being paxed
for the same thing Airbnb is paying and
and all of our brick and mortar hotels
and bnbs are paying uh but
um we heard very little if any
opposition
if I may add to them that um
the one of the other discrepancies here
in which we didn't take into effect
because it doesn't affect the state is
the airport
also charges uh the rental car companies
a 10 fee
on in the state charges the nine percent
so uh you know some of the rental car
companies hurts Davis Enterprise were
paying when they rented a car at the
airport the next 20
and these uh companies that were doing
renting the past privately would still
deliver the cost to the airport
yeah parking in the parking lot have
somebody
pick the car up they would have a cold
they would pick the car up bring it back
to the airport
and not paying the airport 10 percent
fee
now that's a different and quite a few
of the airports in the country got a
hold of this and have made changes we
haven't touched the airport but this is
strictly the state fire but uh you can
see how unfair it is I mean if we want a
fair playing field for our businesses
and these brick and motor businesses uh
contribute a lot I think the manager of
the uh Enterprise is going to also be on
the uh and tell you how many people they
employ and how many how many dollars
they contribute to the economy of the
State of New Hampshire so all we're
asking is to share planes here that's
all this bill does
um again if you want me to get rid of
the nine percent it wouldn't bother me a
bit but assuming that we're going to
keep the nine percent uh I asked that um
you uh consider this bill I know it
passed out a committee last section on a
unanimous vote and uh hopefully we'll
get the same unanimous vote and we can
give a little bit of fairness to uh
those people that are working and
everything else
um any any other questions for the
speaker uh representative Schaumburg
thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative for the
presentation
uh I guess my question comes down
to this do our New Hampshire
entrepreneurial individuals who remain
as individuals seeking to improve their
financial status have to worry about
being classified as a company from now
on the use of the internet to spread
that their own entrepreneurial Spirit
uh no no representative uh and that was
all taken that that's why this bill sat
in this committee last year for two two
years almost before it was passed out of
committee so dra can work on all of the
particulars of it and if I'm correct if
I remember correctly uh They said that
the individual would not be and you
could direct me as a chairman if I'm
wrong I know you worked on this
extensively the individual would not be
the one that would be paying it it would
be the company itself that actually
collects the money correct and it's in
the same the same way that Airbnb done
correct the company collects the money
and then you know turns into percentage
over to you know the person that owns
the small house or whatever
thank you
okay any other questions can I just add
something to that yes thank you I'm
sorry to be out of line on the
the individual under our current law the
individuals are responsible for renting
that car the individuals are responsible
for renting that home whole uh
uh hotel room if they do not pay and the
and the hotel
or the online company does not pay then
the dra can and has sometimes I believe
they can talk to you about it go after
the individual who had no idea he had a
tax to be levied
and makes them pay
is right but um
the uh the thing I'm the thing I'm
saying is that these people that are
renting their private vehicles
uh really don't have a platform unless
you know when something some of the
things were all brought up as well my
neighbor takes my vehicle to go pick up
a refrigerator or something are they
going to have to pay the nine percent
well that's just crazy that's just
Ludacris this is the people that sign up
with these companies like Toro and a few
others out there so they're already in
the system and their cars get rented
through Turlock
or the other companies so it's not like
you're going to have anybody out there
if somebody out there can successfully
individually just rent their vehicle
somehow then
I'm I I realistically don't think uh you
know yeah
a couple of times a year but this is the
company itself the amount of money right
now is small but remember Ubers first
started the amount of people using Uber
was small and then it got bigger and
bigger so if we're going to have a fair
playing field then this is I think the
way we go otherwise make a change in
your taxes uh can I just interject me if
you refer to the second page of the bill
lines 13 through 18.
I think this is addressed
that we can't go after
the person that owns the room or the
vehicle
I think I think we covered that last
year so
it's in the bill yeah it was brought up
last year yeah yeah I think you're
protected
okay very good and it's it's in the bill
but it's in the bill with the basis that
that somebody else is going to pay it
namely the the online company that has
been providing the insurance that has
been providing uh cleaning and all sorts
of things like that
okay so we'll have a discussions when we
when we meet in uh and we'll be meeting
on this bill as a committee thank you
very much Mr Speaker okay thank you
Dennis says I'm sorry sorry we have one
more representative malloying
thank you Mr chair for uh recognizing me
and and uh thank you uh Mr Speaker for
taking my question uh and this is really
for the benefit of the whole committee
I'm hopeful that would you agree that uh
the work that we did on this bill uh
last session was thorough and complete
and it's really
we put a lot of effort into this to make
this right
uh I would agree 100 representative and
that's why it took his you know the two
years to do it and I believe you came
out with a damn good product so
hopefully we can move it forward
thank you okay thank you both thank you
Mr Speaker
okay so we have uh seven seven others
that want to testify so
if we can all be because we're way
behind now
um
if we could try to keep it to three
minutes each that'd be great uh I really
appreciate it uh I won't cut you off uh
if you go a few minutes all over but we
got to kind of keep it down to Adult
World here so we can we can get through
this
so uh we'll start with uh
Carissa
Alexis
uh which represents Enterprise Holdings
are you still there
I thought I put her in there we go I
think I'm unmuted now
Alexis can you also touch why since
you're in a prize I'm assuming that's
Enterprise car rental uh can you touch
on the uh on the airport issue please
yes would um I can definitely touch on
that as part of uh part of what I wanted
to share today and and really just
starting off I wanted to say good
afternoon chairman major Vice chair
abrami members of the committee it's
great to see so many familiar faces I I
know many of you were part of this
unanimous vote to pass the legislation
last session
um for those of you that I don't know my
name is Chris Alexis I'm a New Hampshire
resident I live in Windham my office is
based out of Londonderry and I'm also an
employer of nearly 400 residents with
over 30 locations across the state as
the regional vice president overseeing
Enterprise Holdings operations in New
Hampshire and as of the last time we
were discussing this bill we were proud
to have contributed over eight million
dollars in state tax revenues we spent
over 7 million with local New Hampshire
businesses in the Auto industry and
donated more than forty six thousand
dollars to charitable organizations in
our great state so needless to say but I
will we're heavily invested in New
Hampshire uh to the continued prosperity
of the families we employ into our
communities
so my involvement began
um in this bill began because Enterprise
supports a very simple principle which
is equal rules of the road for all
rental car transactions and I think
speaker Packard represented that
perfectly we are not looking to create
new taxes
um what we do know is the way rental car
transactions are conducted has changed
and evolved since the original tax rules
were written and we're looking to expand
the platforms that are covered to create
a Level Playing Field for everyone
running a car
um Enterprise we've been exploring an
opportunity to offer peer-to-peer car
rentals as well and we want to play by
the rules when we do so making sure
we're paying taxes following consumer
protection safety and privacy laws that
go along with making Vehicles available
for rent to our public because some
peer-to-peer companies claim that these
laws don't apply to them everyone needs
clarities on the rule of the road
when we rolled up our sleeves and really
started digging into this legislation
back in 2019 the opponents argued the
language definitions and premise of the
bill they tried to create fear about
what would happen if the online
platforms were to be taxed the way they
should be they kept offering to work
together to come up with agreeable
language that would address all of their
concerns but after two years of working
on this and the opposite opposition
being given a working platform an open
discussion to make recommendations they
just didn't they kept waning about how
it wouldn't work but didn't really give
us anything to work with
um also in those two years many other
states have passed similar legislation
and has not stifled the growth of the
platforms or any new online rental car
initiatives
um I agree with representative Malloy
our representative worked really hard to
create a bill that was fair and works
here in New Hampshire representative Ami
did a great job leading the discussions
that got us the bill to a place everyone
agreed on and when we passed this
through the committee last year the dra
agreed this bill was easily applied and
enforceable
um so at the end of the day to me uh
this bill is about fairness and we
should not let some peer-to-peer
companies Dodge taxes just as many
states have already decided and other
gig economy debates we're simply asking
for equal rules of the road for everyone
in the car rental space competition is
good and healthy and welcome we just
want a fair shot at winning every rental
we can and we believe in an even playing
field for all rental car providers is
necessary to keep a healthy market and
Industry I believe there was a request
for me to comment on the airport market
and here in New Hampshire we work very
closely with both MHT and PSM and I know
um Ted and the team over at MHT this is
very topical for them and you know he's
had other legislation that he's brought
to the table
um but we have had the support of our
airport directors here as well to create
an even playing field when it comes to
rental uh car transactions and
facilitators years
I don't know if that answered the
question but I'm absolutely open to and
welcome to any other questions the
committee may have okay thank you other
questions are there any uh hands up
please
representative Alma representative Army
please representative
thank you Mr chairman on could you give
us a list of the other states that have
passed similar legislation now because
last time we did this I think
we were the only hold out and there were
some other states considering things
uh correct so we I do have a list and um
maybe I will email that over to you guys
um because I need to pull it up but I do
know when we were talking last session
um there was legislation that was passed
in the state of Maine they split the tax
and the insurance apart I know the
insurance doesn't apply here but the tax
bill that they put through was very much
in line
um with what we were looking to do in
New Hampshire I think our New Hampshire
Bill though works good with what a
legislation and tax rules we already
have in place in the state
um so I can send you a list um that I
have I'll email that over to the
committee
thank you we look forward to seeing that
um any other questions for uh Miss
Alexis
okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you okay next up is uh
Stephen sure
uh from the travel technology
Association who opposes the bill
we open him up
yep I gave him permission
good afternoon members of the committee
are you all able to hear me yes we can
thank you very much thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today
my name is Steve Sher I'm the president
of the travel technology Association I
represent companies like Expedia and
Priceline and verbo
all of whom Inspire and facilitate
travel bookings in the state of New
Hampshire but before I get into the
testimony that I prepared today I wanted
to just
take a moment and reflect on the
speaker's introduction to the
legislation and if this bill is really
about car sharing then I believe that
there's a way to draft the legislation
that that narrowly addresses the car
sharing issue that's not my issue uh
here today my concern with the
legislation is that it
uh it applies the meals and rooms tax to
travel agent fees and I can explain that
and that would apply to not only car
rentals for people who book uh car
rentals through platforms like Expedia
and Priceline but also hotels and
short-term rentals
think of it this way online travel
agents like those companies operate much
like brick and mortar travel agents they
facilitate the booking they don't have
possession of the vehicles or the rooms
uh simply providing a service and what
this bill would do would is would apply
the meals and rooms tax to that new
service fee and it would apply to New
Hampshire travel agents as well
so when you book a room or a car or a
short-term rental on one of those
platforms typically what happens is that
platform collects the room rate or the
car rental rate and all the applicable
taxes and passes those on to the hotel
or to the car rental company for
remittance to the local jurisdiction or
the state and then they also charge the
traveler a small travel agent service
fee that service fee will be subject to
this new tax and that's why in my
testimony that I that I provided in my
Written Letter to the committee as well
as the written testimony of the American
Society of travel advisors we're
concerned that the broad nature of the
use of this tax uh that would apply to
hotel bookings through third party and
travel agents as well as car rentals
would be detrimental to the state as
you're all aware
the pandemic has had a dramatic impact
on the travel and tourism industry
that's no secret to anyone and we just
firmly believe at this point that now is
not the time to tax any aspect of travel
and tourism
uh and rather look ahead towards
recovery we think this tax will have a
negative effect on the recovery in that
it will make accommodations more
expensive and even for New Hampshire
citizens our research shows that about
25 of hotel rooms booked on online
travel sites are in-state bookings and
given the pandemic and travel
restrictions Etc we're seeing actually
higher rates of in-state travel and so
like all taxes this will be passed on to
the consumer in the form of higher room
rates higher car rental rates as those
taxes are recalculated into the total
cost of the trip and so I would urge you
if the true goal of this legislation is
to narrow the focus uh to car sharing
then do so but the way it's drafted now
would unnecessarily tax travel agents
and online travel agents for everything
from hotel hotel bookings to car rental
companies and I'm happy to answer any
questions I appreciate your time did you
uh you said you said something you have
sent something to us
yes I did I sent a letter committee
we'll take a look at that I know we had
this discussion
last year and here before uh
well let us take a look at that um
thanks for bringing it to our attention
um
thank you questions for Mr Shore
representative
representative all me
thank you uh Mr short uh I'm sure you
heard the previous speaker on she said
that uh they'd asked for information
from you and how to
um word things so that it would avoid I
presume this issue which I don't
remember frankly on do you have such
language at this point to share with the
committee
um I certainly could provide that to
many other states have as as was
mentioned previously have have done
something similar and again if the goal
is to address ride sharing harsh I'm
sorry car sharing not ride sharing
um in this context there is a way to
draft the legislation that doesn't
involve
traditional car rental bookings on
platforms like Expedia and Priceline as
well as hotel room bookings on those
same platforms so I'd be happy to follow
up with you and the members of the
committee on that
thank you you realize we don't have a
lot of time so we need it by next week
certainly be happy to provide that in
that time thank you thank you Mr
any other questions from the other hands
up
yeah okay thank you thank you very much
I'm sure
okay next up is uh uh Henry value
um from the New Hampshire lodging and
Restaurant Association uh in support of
the bill
um
I'm trying to find him
doesn't come up in my
I think he may have left I saw him here
here earlier but now I can't find him
okay why don't we uh we'll move on then
Henry if you're out there let us know
but okay
um
okay uh next up would be uh Coral
Zebo Zebo
of net choice in opposition for the bill
yes committee members can you hear me
please yes we can excellent
my name is Carl Zabo I am vice president
and general counsel of net choice and I
do want to thank you all for letting me
speak here today
just be clear I have been fighting for
the past decade vehemently to help
protect New Hampshire from out of state
overreach with respect to online sales
taxes
high five net Choice was the first group
to bring suit against the state of South
Dakota when they tried to Institute
their legislation I filed an amicus
brief at the U.S Supreme Court I've
spoken with many of you on panels and
stood by by you as we defend the rights
of New Hampshire residents to avoid
unlawful taxation from other states
and one thing I noticed that I found
rather jarring to me today was hearing
much of the same rhetoric
that I fought so hard against when it
came to online sales taxation
when it comes to Hotel lodging Services
Taxation and car rental
Services Taxation and it was the Level
Playing Field
unfairness these were terms I heard time
and time again for the past decade
coming from rila and other brick and
mortar stores as they said it's unfair
and we need to level the playing field
the New Hampshire businesses aren't
paying their fair share of taxes
so once again it was very surprising and
and uh frustrating for me to hear those
types of phrases from my colleagues and
uh the representatives in New Hampshire
now speaking to the merits of this
legislation I did submit testimony uh I
opposed both components of it with
respect to the hotel tax as well as the
new tax on car rental now it is
important to be clear that this is a new
tax this is a new tax on services
currently there are only three states in
the union The Tax Services New Hampshire
thankfully is not one of them
but when we're talking about the
services being provided here
this is not where the tax is being
applied the amount of money that it
costs to actually rent a room in a hotel
is being fully taxed today what we're
talking about is applying a new tax to
any additional Services provided by
travel agencies whether it's the service
fee they charge to basically make a
living
called their service fee whether it's a
new tax on part of a bundled provision
so you would still get the occupancy tax
on a hotel room but if we combine that
now with lift tickets or transportation
to ski slopes that's now being taxed at
the occupancy rate that's the effort
that's being sought here and it's being
pushed by big hotels and why do they
want to push this because they don't
want you using small travel agents they
don't want you using online travel agent
websites they want you going directly to
marriott.com and not finding those
boutique hotels who can't otherwise
break out
on the car sharing side
you heard from Hertz well we just want a
fair playing field Level Playing Field
fairness
the number of cars that Tura owns today
in the state of New Hampshire is zero
the number of car rental locations they
have at the airports is zero essentially
what we're talking about is applying a
new tax to the basic action when a
neighbor says can I borrow your truck
now I do appreciate the fact that you
did include in subsection 7 exemption
that you can't go after the individuals
of your state for the collection of
these taxes however with the broad
definition included in the legislation
of the terms of rental uh service
it could easily be applied
to New Hampshire residents and the term
I was referring to is rental
facilitators so broadly written that if
I were the Department of Taxation I
could easily make that apply to New
Hampshire citizens
I would ask that you not Advance this
bill I do appreciate the fact that it
has been worked on for three years but
that doesn't necessarily make it a bill
worthy of moving forward to answer uh
representative almi's question about do
we have recommended language I did
include in my testimony two
possibilities of recommended language
with respect to the uh Hotel occupancy
tax agent component and they both come
as models from Alec who has repeatedly
stood against these forms of new taxes
I was trying to be fast and I covered a
lot so I welcome any questions you may
have thank you for your testimony uh are
there any hands up not in the room any
uh any hands up
okay yes representative
um what types of taxes online
uh businesses like yours or the ones you
represent pay and in what states and how
do you do how is it decided what state
it's paid to
that was that was representative Camaro
by the way yes thank you thank you
representative excellent question so
just to be clear
the uh taxes are always paid so let's
use the example of hotels if I were to
go and use a travel agent
to book a hotel in New Hampshire
that hotel and let's presume the cost of
the hotel is eighty dollars
for the room
a hundred percent of the hotel occupancy
tax on that eighty dollars is paid
now if my travel agent here in Maryland
charged me five additional dollars for a
total of it will be 88 dollars for the
room because that includes the occupancy
tax plus five and they bundle that all
together
the five dollar tax for that service
since they are not a resident of New
Hampshire would not be paid by New
Hampshire now a lot of people especially
those outside of the great state of New
Hampshire have tried to make it seem as
though the Wayfarer decision has let
loose the tax collectors from every
foreign state that is not the case that
decision is narrowly tailored to sales
tax and what we were talking about are
issues well outside the area of sales
tax we are talking essentially about
business service taxes and I can promise
you you do not want in New Hampshire
other states Reaching Across their
borders and trying to apply their
business service or business activity
taxes to New Hampshire businesses
because that's essentially what we're
talking about here
any other questions any other hands up
okay thank you Mr Zebo
we'll take a look at your written
testimony as well thank you thank you
okay next up is uh John Olson
who's with any internet Association in
the opposition of the bill and uh for
the committee I'm going to step away for
a second and representative is going to
take over
thank you so uh so uh so uh Mr Olsen
yes thank you can you hear me yes thank
you
thank you chair and members of the
committee my name is John Olson I'm the
regional director for the internet
Association representing the Northeast
um I represent most of the companies uh
this tax would apply to with respect to
Expedia Airbnb anturo
um I will refrain from repeating my
written testimony I submitted last night
so you should have had time to look at
it I would just say from my perspective
uh representing the internet industry
um you know this is a very unique time
we are still under the throes of a
pandemic and experiencing economic
recovery across the states uh and I
don't think that's any less true in New
Hampshire
uh generally the services that this
rooms and meals tax would be applied to
have become uh almost a Lifeline to New
Hampshire residents in general I think
the car sharing aspect has allowed most
new New Hampshire residents that utilize
turo and other car sharing platforms to
help offset a significant liability in
the form of their vehicle I think the
same can be said for renting out rooms
or second homes through travel platforms
such as the rbo HomeAway or Airbnb uh in
general as Carl mentioned previously
this is a new tax and it's likely a tax
that will either directly be impacting
New Hampshire residents or you know pass
the cost along to them for using these
platforms uh so I would just ask the
committee uh to consider you know the
current environment is this the right
time to uh to assess new fees and taxes
on New Hampshire residents and is it
really a wise decision to use the
platforms as a means of generating
Revenue when they become almost the
exclusive ability for uh folks in the in
New Hampshire and other states from uh
from making a living or earning
supplemental income
and I welcome any questions related to
that or my written testimony thank you
we have a question from representative
thank you Mr chairman uh Mr Olson did
you
um do you have any idea how many much
business tarot does in this state yet
because when we discussed this last year
as I recall there wasn't
so he could wasn't sure we had he had
any customers at all in New Hampshire uh
they were just trying to make sure we
didn't set a precedent which apparently
has been set
I I don't believe that's correct I think
the number from at least last year was
around 4 000 residents utilizing the
platform I can only imagine it's grown
um you know I think you find that
cars have become pretty expensive and
almost
useless piece of property for some
people but you know there are others who
like to travel and find it the most
affordable means of obtaining a car that
they may not otherwise have so I don't
think it's correct to say there are no
customers in in New Hampshire and I
imagine there may be someone from turo
testifying today if not that information
can readily be given to you but in
general I would say New Hampshire does
have many people using turo and using it
to uh to supplement their income in some
respects
thank you for other questions
I don't see anything
so then thank you Mr Olsen thank you
we're going to go to more Weston who's a
lobbyist for Charles or
request I don't believe she's on I
haven't seen her name yet
raise your hand if you're Morrow Weston
looks like she might be mmw
all right then we will go to there's two
people from the era the golf cart and
testifying
[Music]
I believe we do have Morrow Weston
yep she just came on okay yes Maura is
on I'm sorry my computer is labeled mmw
I apologize for that
um can you hear me yes we can wonderful
thank you good afternoon I appreciate
this opportunity to testify today Mr
chair members of the committee my name
is moral Weston and I am testifying
today on behalf of turo which is an
internet-based peer-to-peer car sharing
platform I submitted written testimony
for the record last evening so you
should have that for your review
we testify today in opposition to HB 15.
however I want to stress that my client
and I are willing to work with the
committee on developing a fair way to
address peer-to-peer car sharing as a
unique business model without creating
overly burdensome barriers to entry
turo is an internet platform that
provides a service
a service so that car owner hosts can
list their vehicles for sharing with
guests in need of a vehicle
turo's peer-to-peer car sharing
Marketplace enables New Hampshire
citizens to share their personal car
with neighbors or members of their
community
this Marketplace as I said provides a
service it's an economic opportunity for
New Hampshire car owners to earn a small
amount of extra income
it also provides drivers in search of
Mobility options or specific type of
vehicle a solution
when you think about the implications of
this bill think about the New Hampshire
citizen who's the host think about
perhaps the college student who may only
need to use a car two days a week for
his or her internship and wants to
offset a bit of their debt
or think about the family who's cleaning
out their basement and may perhaps like
to share a pickup truck for a day but
otherwise couldn't afford one
or think about the retiree on fixed
income who doesn't need to use their car
every day of the week and could use a
small bit of extra money to help make
ends meet
peer-to-peer car sharing can also be a
great resource in rural areas where
access to public transportation simply
does not exist
neither tarot nor our host our car
rental companies
neither should be taxed or regulated as
one to be clear turo owns no vehicles
there is no Fleet
the vehicles that are shared are owned
by individual New Hampshire citizens
we do oppose House Bill 15 because we
believe it does in fact create a new tax
on New Hampshire citizens who choose to
share their car
this is akin to taxing a family's
neighborhood lemonade stand as if they
were Minute Maid
currently to answer representative Ami's
question there are about 400 turo hosts
in New Hampshire
and those average host earnings per
month are around three hundred dollars
we are talking about just a small amount
of extra income for people who are
looking to offset debt or make ends meet
in addition to imposing this new tax
the bill and relevant regulations would
require any operator
or host to register with the Department
of Revenue and provide the name and
place of their business within the state
I believe those licenses also have to be
posted
the Taxation and regulation imposed by
this bill is government interference
with the use of personal property
for all practical purposes this bill
would shut down the opportunity for
peer-to-peer car sharing in New
Hampshire
if New Hampshire wants to address
peer-to-peer car sharing we suggest
consideration of the 2019 and coil model
bill
the end coil model provides a regulatory
framework for peer-to-peer car sharing
many states I believe approximately 14
currently have peer-to-peer car sharing
laws on the books there is significant
precedence for treating peer-to-peer car
sharing as distinct and different from
car rental companies
uh the end coil model does that there is
a background from the U.S department of
transportation that distinguishes those
two industries and we would encourage
you to look at that and follow that lead
so today we respectfully oppose House
Bill 15 the new tax it would impose on
New Hampshire citizens but we would be
happy to continue to work with you on
alternative approaches thank you
thank you
[Music]
certainly
did you I'm sorry did you call on me Mr
Speaker or Mr chairman
well I call on
okay okay sorry you're sorry chairman
you're you're just you're a little fuzzy
you're hard to hear
um but thank you
um Ms Weston thank you so much for your
testimony I'm just gonna be really
honest I've been in the hospitality
industry for over 25 years and I'm
actually a customer of churro I'm having
difficulty with your testimony just
because turo is known as the Airbnb of
cars and the fact that you both have a
very similar business model of not
owning a fleet not holding and then
Airbnb doesn't own any hotel rooms or
any rooms you're both providing Services
um I stay at airbnbs when I travel and I
use Toro so I'm very familiar with both
services
Airbnb pays taxes
um they pay into the meals and rentals
tax so my question to you is why do you
think Airbnb should but turo shouldn't
can you continue to hear me
I I believe I believe that Airbnb uh
entered into an agreement with the
Department of Revenue on their own
accord and in fact this bill
um would extend to entities similar to
Airbnb and other platforms
um so we oppose the bill and we do
distinguish our service from Airbnb and
airbnb's made their own business
decisions
um and
um I can't speak for them but we have a
very different position
okay thank you representative Dennis
Maloney
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um and I I I I apologize if this
comes across as
um
I'm trying to be very delicate here uh
in the committee work that we did on
this bill last term if I'm not mistaken
we were presented with printed material
advertising material that said true or
is a car rental company it said that on
this I might be mistaken I might be not
uh remembering quite clearly enough but
in your testimony you said turo uh you
are not you are not a car rental company
so I would ask you to
if you would please uh reconcile those
statements if they need reconciliation
thank you very much sure I'm happy to do
my best I recall that representative
Packard held up some materials last
session that used the word rental and
you know there aren't too many ways to
describe
uh the sharing of something or the use
of something for consideration
um so if the term rental is used on the
turo website it is it's because a host
is looking to share its car for
consideration
um that's the colloquial word would be
rent that doesn't make turo itself a car
rental company we don't have a fleet we
don't own cars we don't rent the cars we
provide a service to our hosts
does that help
thank you very much thank you we'll
we'll work on this in committee sure I'm
delighted to work with you
representative
[Music]
um my question is
what taxes does turo pay now and to whom
um I will have to get back to you on
that turo has no economic Nexus to the
state of New Hampshire it's a California
based entity so I and I'm I'm a New
Hampshire native I'm here on the ground
representing them so I can't answer that
question but I can find out and I can
get back to you thank you sure enough
representing yours
thank you for your testimony uh you said
the turo is a california-based company
do they pay uh while you're doing your
research could you find out if I pay any
taxes in California and just let us know
what the status is certainly certainly
foreign
thank you
thank you for the opportunity
all right we have two people from the
dra
Devon
you both want to speak or another one
oh
yeah
does VRA one
hello Mr chair Carolyn Lear assistant
commissioner at the department of rev I
apologize I couldn't answer your
question because I wasn't yet unmuted
um
very happy to just quickly uh talk to
you about House Bill 15
um as you all know
um we've been talking about this issue
with you for a while
um since the creation of room sharing
and car sharing platforms really every
state in the U.S has been dealing with
the issue of the application of their
rooms and meals or other taxes to these
platform facilitated transactions and
particularly which party the platform or
the property owner is obligated and to
collect obligated to collect and remit
m r tax
um to the state
and additionally whether the tax applies
to the entire price paid by the consumer
as is currently stated in the New
Hampshire m r statute litigation over
this issue has occurred in every single
state and New Hampshire was one of the
last states to receive a decision from
our state supreme court in the Priceline
case which was decided about three years
ago where New Hampshire lost that case
it was a really it was really an
instance where the um the the pace of
technology and
um businesses changing how they operate
wasn't kept up with by the statute
um the proposed legislation would
require room and car rental facilitators
to collect and remit the m r tax for the
transactions they facilitate and
clarifies that the tax applies to the
full price or consideration paid by the
consumer
um these transactions facilitate hated
by these third-party platforms have
always been taxable in New Hampshire
this bill simply clarifies that it's the
platform that's liable for collecting
and remitting this tax I think this is
important and uh speaker Packard talked
about this in his testimony that these
transactions have always been taxable
um the question has just been is it the
platform for the property owner that
must collect and remit we think that the
proposed legislation will improve
compliance because the obligation of
collecting and remitting will fall to
the small number of platforms instead of
the tens of thousands of property owners
um in New Hampshire that are currently
using these platforms and generally
these platforms are the party that also
receives the money including the tax
from the consumer so it seems only
appropriate that they should be the
party um submitting the tax to the state
um so we think that the proposed
legislation could result in an increase
in Revenue due to better compliance
um and overall will serve to help us
more efficiently and effectively
administer the tax and to answer any
questions
you look forward
to me
[Music]
I forgot I didn't have my
on button on sorry Carolyn could you
provide what uh the testimony you said
in writing to the committee
absolutely
thank you
questions
Mr chairman I've got my hand up
representative
thank you Mr chairman on we had a couple
of assertions that I think uh are not in
our law one of them was that if this
passes the individual uh what turo calls
hosts that on
that provide their cars to be rented out
on would have to set up as taxpayers
under your system
no I don't think that's true um I think
the the goal of this legislation is I
understand it is to actually prevent
these off these car owners from having
to individually become licensed instead
um it imposes that obligation on the
platform itself so instead of having
um you know 10 000 operators licensed
you just have one operator who's
licensed and remitting the tax on behalf
of the many
thank you and if I could another on
assertion was that the
on
oh dear which one was it
I should have written all of these down
in a separate place as we went along
on all that on what they're being
charged agency fees which a hotel Etc I
wouldn't pay on when we charge the rooms
and meal Stacks do we separate out the
their cost of advertising and
and um
booking and things
representative only I think that's a
really great question
um so normally when you buy a a room
from a hotel all of the hotels costs are
sort of baked into that one price that
you pay and the m r tax applies to that
full price and certainly some portion of
that is attributable to the advertising
cost of that hotel
um I think that's the logic behind
including these service fees and the tax
base for the m r tax the idea being that
separating out charges isn't um a way to
sort of shave away the underlying tax
base
thank you but could you also say whether
on if you're renting a room at the Mount
Washington and they include three days
of skiing we charge a tax on the three
days of skiing
also a great question the answer to that
would be no
um the statute and rules provide that um
really all that's taxable are charges
that are commonly associated with a room
or a car rental
so for example if your your room rental
has a separate cleaning fee that would
be something that would be commonly
associated with a room rental and the
tax would be applied to it but if you
for example make long distance phone
calls from your room
and there's a separately stated charge
for those long-distance phone calls the
m r tax wouldn't apply to that because
that's not commonly associated with a
hotel stay
thank you can you put those answers also
in what you send us all right thank you
representative
again
um yes thank you Mr chairman
um
my question would be that the discussion
that was about whether individuals would
potentially pay or the sharing app
individuals my understanding of the
business of the proprietorship let's say
proprietorship business profits tax
um you would isn't the threshold fifty
thousand dollars so that if an
individual is making about 300 a week as
was suggested
that wouldn't even get anywhere near the
threshold for for
um filing a BPT proprietorship BPT and
therefore there'd be no tax on the
individual is that correct
that's correct for business profits tax
purposes so you're right you know
someone who's renting their car
occasionally is never going to trip the
threshold for becoming a business tax
taxpayer
um however there is no threshold for the
m r tax so there's no sort of de minimis
threshold where if you engage in
transactions under a certain amount your
transactions aren't subject to tax
okay thank you
any further questions
[Music]
yeah on the
we have
Terry Roy
signed up in opposition
Christopher
you know
representing technique
proposes
and Eric rothburn
member of the public
anybody else come to testify
for uh against the bill
not and I'm closing the public hearing
on Hospital 15 final thank you
that happens sometimes
you know Mr chairman when you gave up
your seat we got behind schedule
[Laughter]
thank you
okay I want to open the public hearing
on House Bill 281--fm
and that relative to the tax expenditure
report and relative to DeLand enactment
the single sales Factor under the
business profits and business Enterprise
tax
the prime sponsor representative Bromley
going to introduced the bill
representative Brown thank you Mr chair
um we're leaving the best for last I
would say and the most complicated for
Less
I'm the only speaker on this other than
the dra so just bear with me here uh I
want to try to use this at the moment
for the new members to try to understand
market-based sourcing and single sales
Factor if you can
and then we'll have more discussions and
what sessions on this
uh but I'm here to introduce first off
the record of the State Rep Pat abrami
Rockingham 19 stratum uh I'm here to
shoot yourself go 281 represent
representative Ames is to co-sponsor
this bill
uh this is a very much a bipartisan bill
from our work from last year another one
of those bills that we've worked on as a
group
and came to our conclusions
if anything this is a
philosophical bills house versus Senate
a senator has a different position on
this bill and we have one on this bill
uh the bill does four things it amends
the tax expenditure uh thank you
men's Which tax expenditures must be
reported upon each year within the tax
percentage report and I'll explain that
in a minute
delays the implementation of single
satisfactor under the BPT from taxable
periods ending on or after December 31st
2022 which is next year's so it's not in
effect right now it'll be in effect next
year
uh to periods ending on or after
December 31st 2026.
you know after I the more I review this
bill uh that that may be a little bit
far out and something we want to talk
about as we proceed here
the third thing is for that period
meaning that the period between 22 and
26 reverts back to the bill also
reverses back to the enforcement
methodology being used for tax tax uh
periods that uh ended on or after on uh
December 31st 2021 which is really this
year's current methodology which for the
first time includes market-based sources
it's all important to know that this is
the first time this year that we we're
including market-based sourcing I'm
going to explain what market-based
sources in a minute
and the final thing it does is it amends
the duties of a legislative Commission
on apportionment
so let's pause a minute and talk about
apportionment
uh what is apportionment and why is it
needed
so if you you hold on the business in
New Hampshire
and you only did business in New
Hampshire you only had brick and mortar
in New Hampshire you had employees
employed here and you're only sold in
New Hampshire
your product
you wouldn't have to worry about
apportionment
because you'd be 100 of of your profits
would be taxed under New Hampshire law
but that's
not what most businesses even smaller
businesses do have a reach into even the
surrounding states like Maine and
Massachusetts Vermont
so
bigger companies have
reach across the country and
internationally as well
so there needs to be a way of
apportioning the profits of a business
across all the states that they in one
way or another do some business in or
have a presidency
so that's what a portionment is
so let's talk about the history
apportionment
years and years ago uh
it was very simple Most states all use
the same methodology
they use the one one the formula was
based on one-third where your sales were
one one-third on your tangible property
Awards I want their way your payroll was
and basically each each they use the
same methodology so it was pretty fair
and consistent approach to uh fortunate
now with time though many states started
to gain this
and they decided that
how can we maximize the revenue coming
to our state
and uh for those of you and I remember
when I was first heard about this I said
well why why isn't there a uniform
approach across all states
the federal government has stayed away
from this question the only way that
would happen is if they decided to have
a law that says that the states will
have the same uh formulas
but there's no directive from the
federal government on this just in case
you're curious
even New Hampshire
a while back took the step of changing
that one-third one-third one-third by
doubling up on the sales portion of it
so not this uh
currently
including tax period this year are
apportionated one half on sales one
quarter untangible property and one
quarter on payroll
so let me let me pause here and just
touch on the the first uh point of the
bill or which is the expenditure report
and then we're going to go back to the
history here
so this this thing called a tax
expenditure report that the dra puts out
every year
and meet in Ways and Means take a look
at that several years ago
uh they presented an is uh I asked the
question because if you go to if you go
to the bill
uh that section is on uh page one line
three to ten
it basically is the language of of the
what's required of the expenditure
report
and you can see we took out
uh we crossed out the weighted
apportionment factors under RSA 77.
that was put in years ago to monitor
what we want to double sale double sales
double sales
and it got to a point where no one was
really looking down at me we wanted to
monitor the progress of that and it was
the sidere said we really don't need
that anymore I was the final I was going
to file the bill simple Bill the
original bill was just to get rid of
that Salesforce that that piece in the
expenditure report
now it'll become clear that that bill
became the vehicle that bill became the
vehicle for other things As Time marched
on here so
so let me continue
now I'm trying to piece this all
together about three or four years ago
we received the Senate bill
uh that was filed by uh
Senator Birdsall
uh something about forming a commission
to study market-based source
and the reason she filed it is he had a
constituent constituent we'll just call
him out
well Al had a business
that brokered food across the country
but all his business was based in New
Hampshire
and market-based sourcing has to do with
Services how do you how do you apportion
services like his where he's a broker
but he broke his products to other
states
that let's use turkeys because that's
that's easy to get food so he would he
would buy turkeys in in the Carolinas
and sell it to supermarkets in
in uh in Maine
the reason I'm using man is you have to
you'll see why in a minute so
so we
uh
so we had this we had this commission we
had this commission that was made up of
a variety of people I'll get to that in
a minute but here's the difference
between what we do
we were doing and what we do now we did
cost of performance and what cost the
performance is is where the service is
performed gets the tax benefit
so New Hampshire it was where
the people doing the brokering in this
case or if you're a computer company
we're doing from their offices in New
Hampshire but providing service to
another state or a company in another
state
all of that tax was apportioned to New
Hampshire
what happened to Al
uh several years ago is that Maine went
to market-based sources
so what's market-based on
where the benefit is where market-based
sourcing emphasizes where the benefit is
received the person the the state that
in which the company is that receives
the benefit is is where the tax benefit
goes so it's just the opposite
so what happened was
there there was Al minding his own
business and he gets a tax notice from
Maine
saying you always all this back taxes
because
you're doing business with this company
name receiving your turkeys
okay and you didn't pay taxes because we
got market-based sourcing and and our
law says that you you owe us money
so uh so
so there's a situation where
both Al of Al you know New Hampshire
collected a tax from him and Main
Collective attacks he was double tasked
for this
so what happened was we did form this
Commission
representative major and I were on it uh
representative Lovejoy
was on it represent around me would stop
by and try to attend as many meetings we
also had
dalessandro and bertzok chaired
uh we had commissioner step on it but we
also had I what I would characterize as
probably the two of the best uh one of
the two of the best tax accountants and
tax lawyers in the state on this
Commission
uh to go through this we actually
extended this commission to make it a
year and a half uh we went through it
all and we concluded at the very end
that that market bait we should go to
market-based sources
so
market-based sourcing is now in effect
this year okay this taxable year that
ends in the periods ending December 31st
of 2001 we forward our
our we are now market-based Force
sources so this year for the first time
well be out from under being double taps
that's all fine and good but what where
a lot of our conversation was is
for us to go to market-based sourcing
the dra has to identify businesses
unless you choose Maine to be simpler
all over the country but let's say Maine
you have to go and find all those
companies in Maine
that are providing services
to New Hampshire
let's say a computer company
okay that the software uh or just you
know but they never set foot in New
Hampshire but they're they're providing
service to companies in New Hampshire we
have to find all those those companies
so that's
that's important because this is part of
our reasoning about wanting to swallow
up a single sales Factor uh we'll get to
that
so
uh but the other thing in that
Commission
we did touch on briefly at the end on
single sales Factor and there were two
senators on this three three house
members we we agreed not to touch single
single sales factor for a while
all right
so
what happened
uh
all right that's what I lost my spot
here
so where are we today
so what happened was last budget
which was let's go back to 2019.
the budget there was a budget the budget
was veto
uh last year who recall there were three
months of of downtime
then it was compromised
and in the compromise
you know one of the last things stuck in
there by the Senate
without hearings for us was single sales
Factor okay
now to appease us
they put
they created our commit a a joint
committee three three house Men Four
house members three senators
and they were supposed to be
twice
and then they were supposed to vote
they were supposed to vote
uh whether to rescind just a single SAS
back
okay
again then the virus hit it was they
never met the first time
and then when they tried and Robertson
around me you can chime in later about
this but my understanding is
that uh this all blew up in a
technicality
that it was basically against our rules
to have a committee Within
something in the budget without going to
the house for the center floor it was it
wasn't allowed although it was in the
world it was it was in what we all
thought we were going to do so so what
what happened was
uh
right now as we sit here single sales
factor is coming
in um
for the taxable periods ending December
uh
uh beginning on or after December 31st
of 2022.
so with this legislative legislation
does
is
we're basically reversing
we're saying we want to delay that
and why do we want to delay that again
the real thing here is that
you wanted to lay it
on market-based sourcing settle in that
one here
and then and then have a baseline of
what happened to the business revenues
and then give us time to
get more and then we're also giving time
for the dra's computer systems
we get more information on it
so we want to buy some time it isn't
like we're against single sash Factory
we just don't want to go on blindly the
reason we don't I say we
this is I'm speaking for the for the
committee what is the means from last
year after this one but
last year we were concerned that if we
make a mistake on this one it could be a
major mistake
you got to understand that what oh I
didn't expect it
single sales factor is do you take away
where the people are you take away what
the client is what you're left with your
abortion simply on sales
so if your sales are out of state
be out of state
gets their credit for not not so if you
look at our upside down triangle for
business taxes
we have a lot of large companies that
work that represent most of our profit
stocks
and what what we're concerned about is a
lot of our manufacturers when you look
at the biggest ones like uh bae
uh their narrow streets you know
they don't sell here
they sell
you know to all over the country
so where we are concerned about what the
impact is going to be
other states because one thing to
Grapple within the commission
but data we want data I know looks at a
major we want data to see what
it's going to do to us unfortunately the
data we really want is very hard to get
at
okay
um so so we wanted to because other
states when we asked about how how did
other states
decide to jump in
no data data decided to jump in
so yeah but
all those other states have an income
tax and a sales tax
this is our major tax business taxes
last two weeks
so we're just trying to build across
this year we're gonna we're making an
attempt
uh to to
slow this down a bit so that we can
actually evaluate the impact of this
I don't think the play is going to be
here in the house it's really going to
be the kids or the Senate
because the senators are going to have
to agree with this is
now
I had a call a zoom meeting yesterday
his
Bill harbinger
one of the probably one of the top tax
guys in the state
reached out to me he said episode
he was he was saying oh you got to
really do this guy you've got to reel it
says super satisfactory
and I said I explained to him
now we're in the house we're a little
more cautious
um but what he said what was passed us
on is that 30 states have done this now
so is it just a matter of time before
New Hampshire does it probably yes
I mean Thursdays
I'm not quite sure if we're surround
advisable sales Factor we'll find that
out right now
so again this is our attempt to slow it
down a bit
of the spell the other thing the bill
does is it that that committee that
joined committee we've reactivated it
and he said let us it'll be a committee
that monitors
partners of market-based sourcing and
going forward
so
that's the big picture of what's going
on
and I'll take questions
representative major I like data
just like I like data questions
thank you my hand is up and you had also
said that maybe I should say something
as well
thank you Mr chairman
on
first of all this is just historical at
this point but on that special committee
I was told during we were told during
the budget and negotiations that uh it
was constitutional for that special
committee to remove the part of the
budget that was about single sales
Factor on six months later the same
person told us that it was not
constitutional and we couldn't do it or
three months later whatever it was no it
was a year uh so
so anyway we are what we're trying to do
is what we really wanted to do back when
we did the special committee which was
to to delay it so that we can have the
time to know how much money we're going
to lose it seems highly likely where
you're going to lose Revenue over this
because we are an elderly State we
consume less than other states and we
have a very large number of
Manufacturers for our size and they
almost all sell most almost entirely
outside the state so they would not be
paying business profits tax
uh if this happens they'd only be paying
bet
and um
but
on
that we we need the bill both to find
out how much we would lose because all
those other states have changed over
we're we're going to have major double
taxation issues we're going to have to
do something at some point but to find
out what's going on and the reason it
goes to 2026 is that on the dra in
orientation told us that they had just
they were just finishing bringing out a
new online tax system they also have a
tax uh analysis system that is in place
now we had very bad data 10 years ago
even a huge very bad data 10 years ago
and
um this will bring us up to par with
most other states at least on and but it
is only going online for the business
taxes this year we are starting
market-based sourcing this year so we
don't know what market-based sourcing is
going to do to these revenues on and we
can't distinguish the businesses that
are selling until this year we can't
distinguish the businesses that are
selling mostly out of state from the
rest of them
in order to be able to do an analysis
and I think dra can say this better than
I can
um but it's going to take two good years
of complete data and we won't have be
mostly complete until a year after the
tax year that we're talking about so
that takes us to Middle 25 which means
that we'd have to pass a bill
426.
so on I see that we've got Carolyn and
Melissa up and I'm going to stop talking
thank you
well thank you
um
can I say something
because I'd like to get the era go ahead
um
so uh
what I what I told
interestingly enough
to probably stand up rather than dra
you know what was missing last year
I need enough senate had hearings on
this but
we like to have errands I told Bill RMG
we get a few companies you think it's a
great idea we want to hear from you
I want to know what aesthetic was told I
want to know what the government was
called
we have no idea what they were talking
and they should come and testify before
us as to what what made them think that
this was risk for you
that that's basically my position I
think most of us had agreed last year
thank you
I think before we go to questions I'd
like to get the IRA
have their input and then we'll go to
questions
okay so uh from the dra we have both
Carolyn and Melissa we both want to
join o1
at least you want to listen from the dra
sure thank you Mr chair for the record
Melissa Rollins again with New Hampshire
Department of Revenue and with me online
also is Karen Carolyn Lear assistant
commissioner for the Department of
Revenue
thank you representative abrami for
doing such a great job of explaining
this bill as well as being supplemented
by representative Ami making my job a
little bit easier
so I'm going to cover section one first
just to get that part out of the way um
because it's sort of quick and easy
representative Brahma you covered this
well the section one of this bill is
really just removing
um the statute for weighted
apportionment Factor under the tax
expenditure report statute for a report
that typically takes us a few hours to
complete yet really doesn't have any
valid information anymore so it's
swapping that out with a now more valid
statute for a new credit Regional Career
and Technical education credit adding
that to the statute so we can make sure
we meet our statutory obligation and
report that each year
so we we really like that part of the
statue
um now on to a market big sourcing
in single sales Factor again I think
representative abrami did a great job
explaining this statue again just as a
high level to hit it again for the new
members cost to Performance is where we
are at last year we just started with
Market base the beginning of this year
so you know 27 days ago
um so cost of performance again is that
when it's intangible sales and services
are portioned based on where the
services was performed
right and now switching to market-based
sourcing starting this year it's where
those intangible sales and services are
now a portioned to where the End
customer is
so that's the biggest difference there
so the timing for this switching those
single sales out and pushing the date
out is really like representative abrami
said is to give time
for
a report to be done and really Analyze
That full impact of Market market-based
sourcing I think again representative
Almy also alluded to this with
market-based sourcing You're Now sort of
switching your customer base you're
pulling in new customers based on those
sales being to the End customer we
didn't have those before so we're
pulling in this new customer base that
we didn't have previously and we're also
losing some because it's people who were
now based at where they perform and they
only Outsource outside of New Hampshire
we're losing those and there's no way
for us to identify that fiscal impact at
this point so in order to get a fiscal
impact we really need the implementation
um pushed out some before single sales
comes in with current law having single
sales start is fine we can administer
that yet it does
um sort of
make the situation a little bit murky
because you have these new taxpayers and
now they're filing single sales and we
don't know which impact is due to which
apportionment change
so it does sound like it's pushed out
far when we say December 31st 2026
however it's important to note that a
tax year doesn't complete until two
years later and that's because of fiscal
year filers so we won't have for just
market-based sourcing alone we won't
have a complete tax year on market-based
sourcing until August of 2023
and that will be our first year and then
it adds another year and there to sort
of get us that compliance going of
getting those new taxpayers on board to
file market-based sourcing so then when
we can file our anticipated report which
is in section three of the bill which is
due November 1st 2024 we now have
relevant data because at that point we
should have the bulk of these
market-based sourcing taxpayers into our
system and we can do that analysis to
say hey what would it look like now if
we switched from that three Factor
apportionment which we are currently at
again payroll property double weighted
sales where we switch it over to that
single sales
Factor so that's the reason for that
push out and then it gives you time to
implement the bill and see what the
fiscal impact is and decide if you if
you want that bill
I think I covered everything I wanted
but happy to answer any questions if I
missed something now that we've heard
from the three experts
do we have any questions
panelists
[Music]
wow you guys have done a great job
there's no questions
correct I don't see any wins don't keep
looking
so um
one name on the blue sheet or Rock bomb
representing himself
and he supports the bill
since there's nobody else there to
testify foreign
care contact versus representative
LeBron in your example you used a
hypothetical gentleman named
we prefer this until 2024. nothing
because
he's a service provider
based Justin New Hampshire this
facilities in New Hampshire
and his employees are in the future
so he won't be impacted by the other two
factors
in other words
he doesn't have facility in other states
and he doesn't have employees working in
other states which are the other two
factors right so he's basically sales
but he's he's a different kind of sales
and that he's
uh Services he providing service sales
of service essentially
where he was paying taxes the two states
don't pay taxes or pain
it will pay no taxes
right now he's paying sometimes
is that correct
it's a little bit hard for me to hear so
I couldn't hear the original question or
the response sorry about that
route
yes
so
um his business is a service business
all this facility is based in New
Hampshire this building
his employees are all in New Hampshire
and uh
and he but he sells to other states
without the product he's buying another
from other states selling a product
never stuck the product never touched
space in New Hampshire for those users
are broken
so the question is if Will single sales
going the single sales Factor impact 10.
I think it will pay no tax in New
Hampshire
in that scenario
okay he's a service company
uh with all this physical plants here
and all those payroll here
what will happen to his taxes
handsome New Hampshire
this is Carolyn Lear assistant
commissioner at the Department of
Revenue I think
certainly single sales Factor would
impact
um this hypothetical taxpayer who has
New Hampshire employees and property
because currently his um tax base is in
part being dictated by his New Hampshire
employees and property that makes up
two-thirds of how we calculate his tax
liability going forward single sales
Factor would be the only way we would um
calculate his New Hampshire tax
liability so his New Hampshire
um employees and property would no
longer dictate his overall tax liability
um that being said I think the
unfairness that this hypothetical
taxpayer was concerned with initially
was mostly the market-based sourcing
versus cost of performance inconsistency
among the states and not so much the
sales Factor
follow up but with that
um
basically he wouldn't be paying any tax
in New Hampshire correct if we want a
single sales Factor
if a taxpayer who has no
um no clients in the state and is
providing services to you know if their
business is the provision of services to
clients and his clients are all future
states he probably does not have a
liability in New Hampshire under single
sales Factor
it's a two-tier thing
I was solved when we went to Miami
resource
and now
we're not really sure
about
so we know that you attractive
all right all right we're going to lose
everyone we want to know how many hours
how many owls are out there in New
Hampshire that are going to not have
that liability but also how many
Sam's are out there from other states
that they're gonna that we can tax okay
now that's done now could could I just
another question yes thank you
um
so I couldn't remember
he wouldn't have to pay bet either so he
would be paying nothing at state level
only his property tax on to to take care
of his employees to take care of his
Public Safety to take care of a whole
range of other government services that
he uses in the state
he'd be paying them to Maine
I was just turning into the discussion
with the chair but uh Melissa our
property
what what uh
he would he has employees here so he
would call him smoking banks in bet
right a taxpayer who has employees in
the state would still pay the BET
um apportionment doesn't really impact
that tax it's only the BPT
always played
we must fall asleep
if there are any other questions
if not then I'm follows the public
hearing Hospital 281
thanks everybody
[Music]
have a good night thank you
thank you